A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. The Merchison is a large bio-region in the state of Western Australia that's known for its agricultural and mining prospects.
清凉的河水流淌过心底。那些汹涌的蓝色波浪可以推动你向前，也可以抚慰你的心灵。从密歇根海岸到密歇根海岸。只要用心感受当下的流动。让那些浩瀚的湖泊、河流和小溪留下永恒的回忆。快来加入我们，在纯净密歇根感受清凉的洗礼。请登录 Michigan.org 了解更多新鲜资讯。默奇森（The Murchison）是西澳大利亚州的一个大型生物区，以其农业和采矿前景而闻名。
Spanning across 281,000 square kilometres, the region is home to many small, sparsely populated towns but consists mostly of rugged outback and arid bushland. During the Western Australian gold rush of the late 1800s, many people flocked to the area in the hopes of securing a fortune which resulted in the construction of several towns that were later abandoned when the short-lived gold rush ended. Afterwards, there was little work available except for agricultural workers, sheep shearers, camel and horse breakers, blacksmiths and boundary riders who were employed to maintain the outer edges of sheep and cattle stations. By the turn of the 20th century, rabbits from the country's eastern states had made their way across the desert and into Western Australia's agricultural areas. European settlers had introduced rabbits to Australia more than 100 years earlier and they eventually became an invasive pest that caused significant damage to the country's ecology and farmland. To combat what became known as the Grey Plague, the Western Australian government decided to build the world's longest fence which stretched all the way from the north coast to the south coast. In 1902, construction of the first phase began in the small wheatbelt town of Barakopin which became the major administration centre for the fence. A 20-foot wide line was cleared through the bush all the way south to a small bay called Starvation Bode Harbour and the mesh fence was then erected two feet west of the centre of the line.
该地区占地 28,100 平方公里，拥有许多人口稀少的小镇，但大部分是崎岖的内陆和干旱的灌木丛。在 19 世纪末西澳大利亚淘金热期间，许多人蜂拥至该地区，希望能发财致富，这导致了几个城镇的建设，后来随着短暂的淘金热结束而被废弃。此后，除了农业工人、剪羊毛工、骆驼和马匹驯马师、铁匠以及受雇维护绵羊和牛场边缘的巡边员之外，几乎没有工作可做。到 20 世纪之交，来自该国东部各州的兔子穿过沙漠，进入了西澳大利亚州的农业区。欧洲定居者在 100 多年前将兔子引入澳大利亚，它们最终成为一种入侵害虫，对该国的生态和农田造成了重大损害。为了打击被称为“灰度瘟疫”的现象，西澳大利亚政府决定建造世界上最长的栅栏，从北海岸一直延伸到南海岸。1902 年，第一阶段的建设在巴拉科平（Barakopin）这个小产粮区小镇开始，该镇成为了栅栏的主要行政中心。穿过灌木丛清理出一条宽 20 英尺的线路，一直向南延伸到一个名为“饥饿博德海港”（Starvation Bode Harbour）的小海湾，然后将铁丝网栅栏竖立在中心线以西两英尺处。
12-foot gates were installed at designated intervals to allow passage through the fence. Wooden posts were also added every mile, each marked with a number that represented the distance from Barakopin. In 1905, the second phase began with the remainder of the fence being built from Barakopin to the far north coast of Western Australia. Stretching for 1,827 kilometres, it became known as the number one rabbit-proof fence. The number two fence was completed in April of 1905 and was 1,158 kilometres long. It began on the south coast, approximately 112 kilometres west of the number one fence and essentially ran parallel to it before turning east and joining the first fence at Gum Creek. The number three fence, which was completed in 1907, started near Geraldton and extended 256 kilometres east until it met the number two fence. Collectively, the rabbit-proof fence was 3,237 kilometres long and building it had cost the equivalent of around 83 million Australian dollars in today's currency.
每隔一定距离安装了 12 英尺宽的大门，以便通过栅栏。每英里还增设了木桩，每个木桩上都有一个代表距离巴拉科平距离的数字。1905 年，第二阶段开始，栅栏的其余部分从巴拉科平建造到西澳大利亚州的远北海岸。它全长 1,827 公里，被称为一号防兔栅栏。二号栅栏于 1905 年 4 月完工，全长 1,158 公里。它始于南海岸，在一号栅栏以西约 112 公里处，基本上与它平行运行，然后向东拐弯，在古姆克里克（Gum Creek）与第一道栅栏汇合。三号栅栏于 1907 年完工，始于杰拉尔顿附近，向东延伸 256 公里，直到与二号栅栏相交。总的来说，防兔栅栏长达 3,237 公里，建造它的花费相当于当今货币的约 8300 万澳大利亚元。
A government sub-department was established to supervise the constant maintenance of the fence. The maintenance team included a chief inspector, sub-inspector, camel drivers, rabbit hunters and boundary riders. Fines were issued to anyone caught leaving the gates along the fence open and it was also an offence for any member of the public to use any of its maintenance tracks. Scattered along the fence were small government-owned stations and homesteads where maintenance supplies, watersheds and other facilities were housed. Caretakers at the stations typically lived a lonely existence as it was common for weeks to go by in which they wouldn't encounter another person or vehicle. Transient workers, travellers and gold prospectors passing through the area would either stay at the stations or at one of the many campsites along the rabbit-proof fence, which had bores containing fresh ground water. Although the outback was isolated and sparsely populated, work was available in the small towns and stations along the fence for men who were willing to tough it out in the harsh conditions. Due to the lack of communication systems at the time and the transient nature of these communities, it wasn't unusual for people to leave without ever being heard from again.
政府成立了一个次级部门来监督栅栏的日常维护。维护团队包括总督察、副督察、骆驼驾驭员、捕兔者和巡边员。任何被抓到敞开栅栏大门的人都会被罚款，公众使用任何维护便道也是违法的。散落在大门沿线的是政府拥有的小型车站和宅基地，里面存放着维护用品、分水岭和其他设施。车站的看守人通常过着孤独的生活，因为常常几个星期都碰不到另一个人或一辆车。过往的工人、旅行者和经过该地区的黄金勘探者会住在车站，或者住在防兔栅栏沿线的众多露营地之一，这些露营地有含有新鲜地下水的钻孔。虽然内陆偏远且人口稀少，但栅栏沿线的小镇和车站为愿意在恶劣条件下吃苦的男人们提供了工作机会。由于当时缺乏通信系统以及这些社区的流动性，人们离开后杳无音信的情况并不罕见。
In the New Zealand city of Gisborne, he received a good education and grew up to be a well-spoken and presented young man. Standing at five foot eight inches tall, Leslie had a medium build, curly brown hair and blue eyes. In December 1926, he married a woman named Minnie and the couple went on to have two children, a daughter named Faye and a son named Desmond. The marriage was an unhappy one, and after a few years, Leslie and Minnie separated. Minnie returned her wedding ring to Leslie, who continued to wear it on the pinky finger of his right hand. It was agreed that Minnie would support herself while Leslie provided for the children, but this arrangement proved difficult given that he was unemployed and virtually broke. Left with few other options, Leslie bordered his children with the Salvation Army at the beginning of 1930. He'd heard rumours that there were jobs available in Western Australia's outback for any able-bodied man who was willing to work and decided to explore this opportunity.
在新西兰城市吉斯本，他接受了良好的教育，成长为一名谈吐得体、仪态端庄的年轻青年。莱斯利身高五英尺八英寸，身材中等，留着一头棕色卷发，有一双蓝眼睛。1926 年 12 月，他与一个名叫米妮的女子结婚，两人育有两个孩子，一个女儿叫费伊，一个儿子叫德斯蒙德。这段婚姻并不幸福，几年后，莱斯利和米妮分居了。米妮把结婚戒指还给了莱斯利，莱斯利继续把它戴在右手的小指上。双方同意米妮自食其力，而莱斯利则抚养孩子，但鉴于他失业且几乎一文不名，这种安排证明是困难的。由于别无选择，莱斯利于 1930 年初将孩子寄养在救世军。他听说西澳大利亚内陆有工作机会，适合任何愿意工作的身强力壮的男子，于是决定探索这个机会。
Eager for a fresh start, he applied for a passport in the false name of Louis John Caron, which he intended to go by from then on and set sail for Western Australia with a stopover in Adelaide. On February 6, 1930, Leslie Brown, now known as Louis Caron, arrived in Fremantle, a port city 20km southwest of Perth in Western Australia. During his journey, he'd been robbed of what little cash he had and left with nothing but a few personal belongings. He went to a pawnbroker in Perth and pawned a suit, one of his only items of value, for 15 shillings, which would amount to $90 AUD in today's currency. At the Perth Railway Station, Louis ran into a man named Jack Lemon, who had travelled to Perth from Adelaide on the same boat as Louis. As they were both looking for work, they decided to team up and head to the Merchison region together. It was a long journey that would take them more than two weeks to complete, during which they'd have to sleep rough to make their money last longer. Jack was in a similar financial position to Louis and only had two pounds, or the equivalent of $240 AUD in today's currency.
渴望重新开始的他，以假名路易斯·约翰·卡隆（Louis John Caron）申请了护照，他打算从那时起使用这个名字，并启程前往西澳大利亚，并在阿德莱德停留。1930 年 2 月 6 日，莱斯利·布朗（现名为路易斯·卡隆）抵达西澳大利亚州珀斯西南 20 公里处的港口城市弗里曼特尔。在旅途中，他身上仅有的一点现金被抢劫一空，只剩下几件个人物品。他去了珀斯的一家当铺，把一套西装（他仅有的有价值的物品之一）当了 15 先令，相当于今天货币的 90 澳元。在珀斯火车站，路易斯遇到了一个名叫杰克·莱蒙（Jack Lemon）的男子，他坐着和路易斯同一艘船从阿德莱德来到珀斯。由于他们都在找工作，他们决定组队一起前往默奇森地区。这是一段漫长的旅程，将花费他们两个多星期的时间才能完成，在此期间他们必须风餐露宿以延长资金的使用期限。杰克的财务状况与路易斯相似，只有两英镑，相当于今天货币的 240 澳元。
Desperate for money, Louis sent a telegram to a friend in New Zealand, explaining his dire financial situation and asking for a loan. He requested that the money be telegraphed to Geraldton, a coastal city approximately 400km west of the Merchison region. After Louis sent the telegram, the two men began their long journey. Louis and Jack took the suburban rattler train from Perth to the Midland Junction Railway Station, where they then set off on foot, carrying their belongings in swags. They spent the next few days hitching rides where possible and were occasionally provided with food along the way. Jack drank pots of beer while Louis, who didn't drink alcohol, favoured lemon squash. Without much money to spend on accommodation, they made do with what they could find. On one occasion they slept in a wheat sack, while another time they tried to sleep in some sand dunes, but were thwarted by ants.
由于极度缺钱，路易斯给新西兰的一个朋友发了一封电报，解释了他可怕的财务状况并请求贷款。他要求将钱电汇到杰拉尔顿，这是一座位于默奇森地区以西约 400 公里的沿海城市。路易斯发出电报后，两人开始了漫长的旅程。路易斯和杰克乘坐郊区小火车从珀斯前往米德兰交汇火车站，在那里他们步行出发，把行李装在行军袋里。在接下来的几天里，他们尽可能地搭便车，一路上偶尔能得到食物。杰克喝着一罐罐的啤酒，而路易斯不喝酒，偏爱柠檬水。由于没有多少钱用于住宿，他们有什么就将就什么。有一次，他们睡在一个小麦麻袋里，而另一次，他们试图睡在沙丘里，但遭到了蚂蚁的阻挠。
Once they arrived in Geraldton, Louis received the funds that had been sent by his friend in New Zealand, giving him a total of five pounds, or the equivalent of around $600 AUD today. The two men used some of this money to send their heavy swags ahead on a freight train to the Merchison gold mining town of Mount Magnan. They then walked and hitched the remainder of the way. Mount Magnan was located near the 206 mile gate of the number one rabbit-proof fence. When Louis and Jack arrived in town, they gathered their belongings and began visiting the local stations looking for work. Within a few days, Jack secured a short-term job working as a station hand at Naur Barra station, while Louis found work at Wiggy station. The two had forged a strong friendship during their time on the road, and while in their new jobs, they began writing to one another fortnightly. Louis was an avid letter writer and also wrote regularly to his family and friends back home in New Zealand.
一到达杰拉尔顿，路易斯就收到了他新西兰朋友寄来的资金，使他总共拥有五英镑，相当于今天的约 600 澳元。两人用其中的一些钱通过货运列车将他们沉重的行军袋提前运往默奇森金矿小镇芒特马格南（Mount Magnet）。然后他们步行并搭便车走完了剩下的路。芒特马格南位于一号防兔栅栏 206 英里大门附近。当路易斯和杰克到达镇上时，他们收拾好行李，开始拜访当地的车站寻找工作。几天之内，杰克在瑙尔巴拉车站（Naur Barra station）找到了一份车站杂工的短期工作，而路易斯在威吉车站（Wiggy station）找到了工作。两人在路上结下了深厚的友谊，在各自的新工作岗位上，他们开始每两周写信一次。路易斯是个狂热的信件写作家，也经常给远在新西兰的家人和朋友写信。
By mid-1930, the Merchison area was feeling the impact of the depression, and many station hands lost their jobs, including Louis. He wasn't overly concerned, as he was confident it wouldn't take him long to find another job. On his search for employment, he planned to travel to the Hamlet of Campion, where Jack Lemon was now living, to pay him a visit. Jack was staying at the fountain, a Stockman's hut and out camp located alongside the rabbit-proof fence between Camel station and Nandi station. It was a remote area characterized by desert sands, mulga scrub and acacia trees, and it mostly had winding bush tracks instead of paved roads. The closest towns were Painesville, a one-stop former gold mining town 120km to the north, and Ewan Mee, another former mining town 65km northeast via bush tracks. Jack Lemon was thrilled when he heard that Louis was heading his way. He mentioned the news to Snowy Rolls, a 27-year-old self-employed dogger and foxtrapper who had been coming and going from the fountain campsite.
到 1930 年年中，默奇森地区开始感受到经济大萧条的影响，许多车站杂工失去了工作，包括路易斯。他并不太担心，因为他相信自己很快就能找到另一份工作。在寻找工作期间，他计划前往坎皮恩村（Hamlet of Campion），杰克·莱蒙现在住在那里，去拜访他。杰克住在喷泉营地，这是一个位于骆驼站和南迪站之间的防兔栅栏沿线的牧人小屋和外围营地。这是一个偏远的地区，其特点是沙漠沙地、金合欢灌木丛，主要由蜿蜒的灌木小路而不是铺装道路组成。最近的城镇是佩恩斯维尔（Painesville），这是一个位于北方 120 公里处的一站式前金矿小镇，以及埃万米（Ewan Mee），另一个通过灌木小路位于东北 65 公里的前矿业小镇。杰克·莱蒙听到路易斯要来他这边时非常高兴。他把这个消息告诉了斯诺伊·罗尔斯（Snowy Rolls），一个 27 岁的个体户猎狗人和捕狐人，他经常出入喷泉营地。
Snowy asked Jack whether Louis might be interested in working with him as he's off-sider. This idea pleased Jack, as he liked Snowy, and was happy that Louis would be able to stay in the area. Snowy had been working throughout the Merchison since 1928 and had earned a reputation as a skilled bushman and respected Jack of all trades. He had a charming disposition and was known for his keen sense of humour, composed temperament and willingness to oblige. Louis arrived at the fountain campsite on May 17, 1930, and he, Jack and Snowy stayed up chatting well into the evening. Louis was in good spirits, and at one point he mentioned that he had recently made several purchases, including a pair of high-quality hair clippers. He'd also sent two of his watches to Perth for repairs and had paid to buy his suit back from the pawnbroker, though he still needed to collect it. He also flashed his final Wiggy station paycheck for £25, which was the equivalent of around $3,000 in today's currency.
斯诺伊问杰克，路易斯是否有兴趣和他一起工作，担任他的助手。这个想法让杰克很高兴，因为他喜欢斯诺伊，而且很高兴路易斯能留在该地区。自 1928 年以来，斯诺伊一直在整个默奇森地区工作，并赢得了熟练的丛林人和受人尊敬的万事通的名声。他性格迷人，以敏锐的幽默感、镇定的气质和乐于助人的精神而闻名。路易斯于 1930 年 5 月 17 日抵达喷泉营地，他和杰克、斯诺伊一直聊天到深夜。路易斯精神很好，有一次他提到他最近买了几样东西，包括一把高质量的理发推剪。他还把他的两块手表送到珀斯修理，并花钱把他的西装从当铺赎了回来，尽管他还需要去取。他还亮出了他最后一份价值 25 英镑的威吉车站薪水支票，这相当于今天约 3000 澳元的价值。
The money amounted to approximately five weeks' pay, and Louis aimed to live off it for the next two months. This seemed possible, as he didn't drink or have a car to maintain. He agreed to work as Snowy's off-sider until something more permanent arose, and the two decided to see what job opportunities were available in the remote town of Waluna. The following day, the men loaded up Snowy's 1926 Dodge Utility truck and took turns posing for photos in front of the vehicle. Louis told Jack he'd return in around five weeks, then he and Snowy headed off towards Waluna. Five weeks passed, but Jack didn't see or hear from Louis again. This was unusual, as the two wrote to one another regularly. In June, Jack heard through the grapevine that Snowy was back in the Ewanme area, so he sent a reply-paid telegram to Snowy, care of the Ewanme Post Office, inquiring as to Louis's whereabouts.
这笔钱大约相当于五个星期的薪水，路易斯的目标是靠它生活接下来的两个月。这似乎是可能的，因为他不喝酒，也没有汽车需要维护。他同意担任斯诺伊的助手，直到出现更稳定的工作，两人决定看看偏远小镇瓦卢纳（Waluna）有什么工作机会。第二天，男人们把斯诺伊 1926 年产的道奇皮卡车装满，并轮流在车前摆姿势拍照。路易斯告诉杰克他大约五周后回来，然后他和斯诺伊朝瓦卢纳方向出发了。五周过去了，但杰克再也没有见到或听到路易斯的音讯。这很不寻常，因为两人经常互通信件。六月份，杰克从小道消息听说斯诺伊回到了埃万米地区，于是他给埃万米邮局转交了一封回资电报给斯诺伊，询问路易斯的下落。
With a population of around 45, Ewanme offered nothing more than a general store, a post office, a bank, a pub, a cafeteria, and a small hospital, meaning it was nearly impossible for anyone to pass by unnoticed. Jack explained that the telegram was urgent, but he never received a response. On August 9, Jack wrote a letter directly to Snowy. Snowy replied, explaining that he had responded to the original telegram and was unsure why Jack didn't receive it. He said that he and Louis had first travelled to Mount Magnan, but Louis had then continued on his own into Geraldton. Louis had promised Snowy he would send some photographs, but Snowy never heard from him again. Snowy urged Jack to come for a visit, writing, I will explain to you better. I'm no good at writing letters, as you can see by this. I'll be going away for a few weeks. I'll write when I come back.
埃万米拥有约 45 名人口，只提供杂货店、邮局、银行、酒吧、自助餐厅和小型医院，这意味着任何人几乎都不可能毫无察觉地路过。杰克解释说这封电报很紧急，但他从未收到回复。8 月 9 日，杰克直接给斯诺伊写了一封信。斯诺伊回信解释说，他已经回复了最初的电报，并且不确定为什么杰克没有收到。他说他和路易斯首先去了芒特马格南，但路易斯随后独自一人去了杰拉尔顿。路易斯曾向斯诺伊承诺他会寄一些照片，但斯诺伊再也没有听到他的消息。斯诺伊敦促杰克来看看，写道：“我会向你更好地解释。我不擅长写信，正如你从这封信中看到的那样。我要离开几个星期。我回来后会写信。”
The letter did nothing to ease Jack's concerns. It made sense to him that Louis would have travelled to Geraldton, but he couldn't understand why he would stop writing if everything was okay. Jack wrote to Geraldton inquiring about his friend, but with no result. He also wrote to the pawnbrokers in Perth to see if Louis had collected his suit yet, but he had not. By this point, Jack was growing increasingly worried about his friend's safety. Meanwhile, in the New Zealand city of Dunedin, Louis' friend, WA Jackson, was also worried. He hadn't heard from Louis since May, which was suspicious given how prolific he was at letter writing. Jackson wrote directly to the Mount Magnant police, who got his letter on December 31, 1930. Due to the transient nature of many workers in the area and to the limited means of communication available, the police were accustomed to receiving many such inquiries every year.
这封信根本无法缓解杰克的担忧。在他看来，路易斯去杰拉尔顿是合乎情理的，但他不明白为什么如果一切正常，他会停止写信。杰克写信给杰拉尔顿询问他的朋友，但没有结果。他还写信给珀斯的当铺，看路易斯是否已经取回了他的西装，但没有。此时，杰克对朋友的安全越来越担心。与此同时，在新西兰但尼丁市，路易斯的朋友 W.A. 杰克逊（WA Jackson）也很担心。自 5 月以来，他一直没有路易斯的音讯，考虑到他写信如此多产，这很可疑。杰克逊直接写信给芒特马格南警察局，他们于 1930 年 12 月 31 日收到了他的信。由于该地区许多工人的流动性质以及可用的通信手段有限，警方已经习惯于每年接到许多此类查询。
As most of the people in question turned up in due course, no further action was taken to find Louis. Almost a month later, on January 21, 1931, Jack spoke with Constable Walter Hearn of the Mount Magnant police. He reported that his friend, Louis Caron, hadn't written to him since leaving the Fountain Out camp in May of 1930. Constable Hearn recalled the letter he'd received a few weeks earlier from WA Jackson of Dunedin, who was also inquiring about Louis. The Constable was due to take annual leave, but decided to postpone his departure so that he could get to the bottom of the matter. On February 17, 1931, Constable Hearn was joined by Constable Christopher MacArthur, who was a veteran bushman, and the two set out to make inquiries. They travelled 320km north of Mount Magnant to Waluna, the location where Louis and Snowy had initially told Jack they were heading to look for work. No one in Waluna recalled ever seeing the two men, so Constable Hearn and MacArthur headed south down the Rabbitproof Fence to Camel Station, where they set up their investigation headquarters.
由于大多数相关人员最终都会出现，因此没有采取进一步的行动来寻找路易斯。将近一个月后的 1931 年 1 月 21 日，杰克与芒特马格南警察局的沃尔特·希恩（Walter Hearn）警员交谈。他报告说，他的朋友路易斯·卡隆自 1930 年 5 月离开喷泉营地以来就没有给他写过信。希恩警员回想起几周前收到的一封来自但尼丁的 W.A. 杰克逊的信，他也一直在询问路易斯。这位警员本该休年假，但决定推迟离开，以便查明事情的真相。1931 年 2 月 17 日，希恩警员与资深丛林人克里斯托弗·麦克阿瑟（Christopher MacArthur）警员汇合，两人出发进行调查。他们向北行走了 320 公里，来到芒特马格南以北的瓦卢纳，这是路易斯和杰克最初告诉杰克他们要去寻找工作的地方。瓦卢纳没有人记得见过这两个人，于是希恩警员和麦克阿瑟警员沿着防兔栅栏向南前往骆驼站，他们在那里建立了调查总部。
The police soon learned that on May 20, 1930, two days after leaving the Fountain Out camp, Snowy rolls had driven through Painesville and stopped at the town pub, which was owned by Ted and Laura Moses. He asked Laura if she could cash a check for £25, but Laura didn't have enough money to do so. She advised Snowy to speak to her husband, Ted, who indicated they would have enough cash later that day. At around six o'clock in the evening, Snowy returned to the pub and told Ted he also needed petrol and supplies. He agreed it could wait until morning, and decided to spend the night in one of the pub's rooms. The following morning, Snowy loaded his Dodge with petrol, groceries, a pair of boots, a gold panning dish, and a few other small items. To pay for his haul, he handed over a check for £25 that was made out in the name of Louis Caron. When Ted asked who Louis was, Snowy replied,
警方很快得知，1930 年 5 月 20 日，即离开喷泉营地两天后，斯诺伊·罗尔斯驾驶汽车穿过佩恩斯维尔，并在由泰德和劳拉·摩西（Ted and Laura Moses）拥有的城镇酒吧停了下来。他问劳拉是否可以帮他兑现一张 25 英镑的支票，但劳拉没有足够的钱。她建议斯诺伊和她的丈夫泰德谈谈，泰德暗示他们当天晚些时候会有足够的现金。傍晚六点左右，斯诺伊回到酒吧，告诉泰德他还需要汽油和补给。他同意可以等到早上再弄，并决定在酒吧的一个房间里过夜。第二天早上，斯诺伊的道奇车里装满了汽油、杂货、一双靴子、一个淘金盘和其他几件小物品。为了支付他的采购费用，他交出了一张以路易斯·卡隆的名义开出的 25 英镑支票。当泰德问路易斯是谁时，斯诺伊回答说，
He's my mate. We're camped out in the bush and he's looking after the fox traps. He's probably thirsty by now. I'd better get some beer for him. After placing the beer in the car, Ted accepted the check and gave Snowy his change in the form of a £17 check and some small cash. Snowy gave the Dodge some maintenance and told Ted that he was heading to Waluna. He then drove out of Painesville, but instead of heading north to Waluna, he turned south towards Ewanme. Constable Hearn interviewed Jimmy and Charlotte Jones, who owned the general store in Ewanme. They confirmed that Snowy Roles had arrived in town a few days after leaving Fountain Camp with Louis, but nobody in Ewanme had actually seen Louis. The police soon learned that Snowy was now working at Hillview Station near Meekathara, a small town 190km north of Mount Magnet. The Constables worked their way along the bush tracks from the Fountain Out Camp in order to retrace Snowy's route to Painesville and on to Ewanme.
“他是我的朋友。我们在丛林里露营，他在照看狐狸夹。他现在可能口渴了。我最好给他买点啤酒。”把啤酒放进车里后，泰德接受了支票，并以一张 17 英镑的支票和一些零钱的形式找零给斯诺伊。斯诺伊对道奇车进行了一些维护，并告诉泰德他要前往瓦卢纳。然后他驱车离开佩恩斯维尔，但没有向北去瓦卢纳，而是向南转向埃万米。希恩警员采访了吉米和夏洛特·琼斯（Jimmy and Charlotte Jones），他们拥有埃万米的杂货店。他们证实斯诺伊·罗尔斯在离开与路易斯在一起的喷泉营地几天后来到了镇上，但埃万米没有人真正见过路易斯。警方很快得知，斯诺伊现在正在芒特马格南以北 190 公里的小镇米卡萨拉（Meekathara）附近的希尔维尤车站（Hillview Station）工作。警员们沿着从喷泉营地出发的灌木小路前行，以便重现斯诺伊前往佩恩斯维尔并前往埃万米的路线。
Even though more than nine months had passed since Louis and Snowy left on their journey, tire marks remained in the area for a long period of time due to the isolation and the police were hoping to find some clues. They eventually reached the 183-mile gate on the number one rabbit-proof fence, which was located in an isolated spot populated by dense, narrow-leafed mulga shrubs. The gate was rarely used, as it merely opened to a remote 800m track that led to a small iron hut and campsite that had no access to water. A boundary rider was required to check on the hut's condition twice a year, but other than that, people seldom had any reason to visit and few likely knew of its existence. After deliberating whether or not to check out the campsite, the Constables decided to venture through the gate and down the track. 300m west of the hut was a dysfunctional water bore, and within the vicinity of this bore, the Constables found evidence of a large fire having been burned. They scoured the ashes and soon found a number of bone fragments, including what appeared to be pieces of a human skull. They also found animal bones, charred woollen material, and a button made of bone.
尽管距离路易斯和斯诺伊踏上旅程已经过去九个多月，但由于该地区的偏远，车轮痕迹在该地区保留了很长时间，警方希望能找到一些线索。他们最终到达了一号防兔栅栏上的 183 英里大门，这里位于一个由浓密的小叶金合欢灌木丛构成的偏远地点。这扇门很少使用，因为它只通向一条通往小型铁皮小屋和没有水源的露营地的偏远 800 米小路。一名巡边员每年需要检查两次小屋的状况，除此之外，人们很少有理由去参观，而且可能很少有人知道它的存在。在商量是否要查看营地后，警员们决定冒险穿过大门并沿着小路前行。小屋以西 300 米处有一个失灵的水井，在这个水井附近，警员们发现了曾经发生过大火的证据。他们在灰烬中搜寻，很快发现了一些骨骼碎片，包括看起来像是人类头骨碎片的东西。他们还发现了一些动物骨骼、烧焦的羊毛材料和一个骨头做成的纽扣。
After detecting the remnants of ash trails, the Constables followed them deeper into the bush, where they discovered two more piles of ash. The grass under these piles hadn't been burned, indicating that the ashes had been dumped at these locations rather than burned there. Among the ash, the Constables found artificial teeth, gold clips from a dental plate, metal eyelets from a pair of shoes, and a wedding ring. Convinced they had discovered evidence of foul play, Constables Hearn and MacArthur sent the evidence back to the Mount Magnant police station. Detective Sergeant Harry Manning, a revered investigator from the Perth Criminal Investigation Department who had spent many years working in the bush, was assigned to lead the case. He departed for Mount Magnant immediately, and after arriving on March 1, 1931, he and Constable Hearn returned to the 183-mile gate to conduct a more thorough examination of the camp. Inspection of the main fire site determined it had measured 8 feet by 6 feet, with the ground underneath burnt to a depth of 3 inches. A nearby coffee tin had been severely scorched on one side, indicating the fire had been very intense.
在发现灰烬痕迹的残留物后，警员们顺着它们深入灌木丛，在那里他们发现了另外两堆灰烬。这些堆积物下的草没有被烧毁，这表明灰烬是被倾倒在这些地方的，而不是在那里被烧毁的。在灰烬中，警员们发现了假牙、牙托上的黄金夹、一双鞋子的金属孔眼和一枚结婚戒指。确信他们发现了谋杀的证据后，希恩警员和麦克阿瑟警员将证据送回了芒特马格南警察局。哈里·曼宁（Harry Manning）侦探中士是珀斯刑事调查局的一名受人尊敬的调查员，他在丛林中工作了多年，被指派领导此案。他立即动身前往芒特马格南，在 1931 年 3 月 1 日抵达后，他和希恩警员返回 183 英里大门，对营地进行更彻底的检查。对主要火灾现场的检查确定其长 8 英尺、宽 6 英尺，底部的地面被烧焦了 3 英寸深。附近的一个咖啡罐一面被严重烧焦，这表明火势非常强烈。
The officers sifted through the ashes using a fine mesh sieve and discovered more bone fragments, a molar tooth, and several unusual wire stitches. Detective Manning also inspected the camp oven near the main fire and noticed that ash was stuck to the outside. To him, this suggested that the oven had been used to transport some of the ashes to the other two piles. Tire tracks from a car or truck led from the 183-mile gate to the side of the fire and then back again. The officers returned to town and Detective Manning started gathering witness statements. Louis' friend, Jack Lemon, confirmed that Louis had false teeth as he had seen him clean them on several occasions. Detective Manning began inquiring with dentists and orthodontists throughout Western Australia and New Zealand. He soon discovered that a dentist named Arthur William Sims had constructed dentures for Louis that consisted of a complete lower set of artificial teeth and a partial upper set that could be fixed to Louis' existing teeth using two gold clips, similar to those found in the ashes.
警官们用细网筛过滤灰烬，发现了更多的骨骼碎片、一颗磨牙和几个不同寻常的铁丝订书钉。曼宁侦探还检查了主火炉附近的露营烤箱，注意到灰烬粘在外面。对他来说，这表明烤箱曾被用来将一些灰烬运送到其他两个堆里。汽车或卡车的轮胎痕迹从 183 英里大门一直延伸到火灾现场的一侧，然后再返回。警官们回到镇上，曼宁侦探开始收集证人证言。路易斯的朋友杰克·莱蒙证实路易斯有假牙，因为他曾多次看到他清洗假牙。曼宁侦探开始向西澳大利亚州和新西兰的牙医和正畸医生询问。他很快发现，一个名叫亚瑟·威廉·西姆斯（Arthur William Sims）的牙医为路易斯制作了假牙，其中包括一副完整的下牙托和一副可以固定在路易斯现有牙齿上的部分上牙托，使用的是两个黄金夹，类似于灰烬中发现的那些。
Jack Lemon also confirmed that Louis wore a wedding ring that was, quote, so tightly fitting that he once said he would have to have it filed off. Detective Manning tracked down Louis' ex-wife, Minnie Brown, in New Zealand, who said her former husband's wedding ring had been bought from a jeweller named A.T. Long. Mr Long examined the ring found in the ashes and determined that its unique markings and parent number confirmed it had been made in New Zealand. He also recognised a visible discolouration in a join on the ring, which had been made by one of his inexperienced employees during the resizing process. Mr Long recalled that it had been resized at Louis Caron's request, confirming it to be his wedding ring. Detective Manning learned that prior to Louis' disappearance, he had sent two of his watches for repairs to a jeweller in Perth named Levinson & Sons on April 11, 1930. One was an open-faced Omega pocket watch, and the other was a wrist watch. Detective Manning contacted Levinson & Sons, who had recorded details of the repair in their register.
杰克·莱蒙还证实路易斯戴着一枚结婚戒指，用他的话说，“紧紧地套在手指上，以至于他曾说过他不得不把它锉掉”。曼宁侦探在新西兰找到了路易斯的前妻米妮·布朗，她说她前夫的结婚戒指是从一个叫 A.T. 朗（A.T. Long）的珠宝商那里买的。朗先生检查了灰烬中发现的戒指，并确定其独特的标记和父本编号证实它是新西兰制造的。他还认出了戒指连接处可见的变色，这是由他的一名经验不足的员工在调整尺寸过程中造成的。朗先生回忆说，这枚戒指是应路易斯·卡隆的要求调整尺寸的，证实这就是他的结婚戒指。曼宁侦探得知，在路易斯失踪之前，他曾于 1930 年 4 月 11 日将他的两块手表送到珀斯的一家名为莱文森父子公司（Levinson & Sons）的珠宝商那里修理。一块是开放式欧米茄怀表，另一块是手表。曼宁侦探联系了莱文森父子公司，他们把维修的细节记录在他们的登记册中。
After the watches were repaired, they were returned on April 29 in a cardboard box. The box had been constructed using wire stitches, similar to those found in the ashes of the fire. The manufacturer of the box that contained Louis' repaired watches recognised the stitches, as they had a slight defect that matched the floor in one of his machines. Levinson & Sons also said that on June 29, 1930, a jeweller from Mount Magnant named Fleming & Co. had sent them Louis' same two watches seeking further repairs. Detective Manning spoke to the owner of Fleming & Co. who confirmed that the person who had brought the watches to him for repair was Snowy Rolls. Louis' travel companion when he was last seen leaving the fountain outcamp on May 18, 1930. Detective Manning followed the trail that Snowy and Louis had initially set out on. As later stated by author Arthur Upfield, he covered hundreds of kilometres, filling books with notes about various places, distances, dates and names.
手表修好后，于 4 月 29 日用一个纸盒退回。这个盒子是用铁丝订书钉制作的，类似于火灾灰烬中发现的那些。制造装有路易斯修好手表的盒子的制造商认出了订书钉，因为它们有一个轻微的缺陷，与他的一台机器上的地板相匹配。莱文森父子公司还表示，1930 年 6 月 29 日，芒特马格南的一名名为弗莱明父子公司（Fleming & Co.）的珠宝商将路易斯相同的两块手表送给他们，要求进一步修理。曼宁侦探与弗莱明父子公司的老板交谈，后者证实，将手表带给他修理的人是斯诺伊·罗尔斯。路易斯在 1930 年 5 月 18 日最后一次被看到离开喷泉营地时的同行伙伴。曼宁侦探沿着斯诺伊和路易斯最初出发的路线追查。正如作家亚瑟·厄普菲尔（Arthur Upfield）后来所述，他走了几百公里，写满了关于各个地方、距离、日期和名字的笔记。
Eventually, he had the name of every working man who was in the district at the time of Louis' disappearance. Word had it that Snowy Rolls was currently employed on Hillview Station. Those who knew him described him as a man of excellent character and a fine bushman. Detective Manning learnt that Snowy had purchased his 1926 Dodge Utility truck from a man named James Ryan who had since left the district. According to locals, James Ryan had left Bernandie Station with a man named George Lloyd in early December of 1929 and neither of the men had been seen for almost 18 months. James Ryan was a former sailor aged in his early 50s. Known as a tough man, he was five feet eight inches tall, heavily tattooed and spoke with a thick cockney accent. He'd arrived in the Merchison area around 1920.
最终，他掌握了路易斯失踪时该地区每一位工人的名字。据传，斯诺伊·罗尔斯目前受雇于希尔维尤车站。认识他的人形容他是一个品格优良、优秀的丛林人。曼宁侦探得知，斯诺伊是从一个名叫詹姆斯·瑞安（James Ryan）的人那里买下他的 1926 年道奇皮卡车的，此人后来离开了该地区。据当地人说，詹姆斯·瑞安在 1929 年 12 月初与一个名叫乔治·劳埃德（George Lloyd）的人离开伯纳迪车站（Bernandie Station），这两个人已经有将近 18 个月没有露面了。詹姆斯·瑞安是一名年过五旬的前水手。他被称为一个硬汉，身高五英尺八英寸，身上有大量纹身，说话带有浓重的伦敦腔。他大约在 1920 年来到默奇森地区。
Rumours spread that he had deserted the Royal Navy to work in Calgooly's gold mines. For years, James had mostly been based at the former Gold Rush sites of Pains Find and Mount Magnon where he was known for being a conscientious worker and an excellent singer. He was also known to drink a lot and had been arrested a number of times for drunkenness as well as thrown out of all three pubs in Mount Magnon on various occasions. In mid-1929, James travelled to Perth to purchase a 1926 Dodge Touring Car that had been converted into a light utility truck. He drove it north to Nandi Station to begin his next work assignment. He was hired by the station manager Herman Bogle to build a fence along the eastern edge of the station. James set up camp at the newly constructed Chally Boar, a campsite and water access site that contained little other than a water tank, a shed and yards. His first task was to clear a long strip of land through the mulgar scrub, known as a skyline, and then erect the fence down the centre.
有传言称他曾逃离英国皇家海军，去卡尔古利的金矿工作。多年来，詹姆斯主要驻扎在帕因斯芬德（Pains Find）和芒特马格南这两个前淘金热遗址，他在那里以工作认真、歌声优美而闻名。他也众所周知酗酒，曾多次因醉酒而被捕，并在不同场合被赶出芒特马格南的所有三家酒吧。1929 年年中，詹姆斯前往珀斯购买了一辆被改装成轻型皮卡车的 1926 年道奇旅行车。他把它向北开往南迪站，开始他的下一项工作任务。他被车站经理赫尔曼·博格尔（Herman Bogle）雇佣，沿车站东缘修建栅栏。詹姆斯在新建的查利博尔（Chally Boar）建立了一个营地，这是一个露营地和水源获取点，除了一个水箱、一个棚子和院子外，几乎没有别的。他的第一个任务是在金合欢灌木丛中清理出一长条土地，被称为地平线，然后沿着中心竖起栅栏。
It would take approximately four months of solid work, which meant James was scheduled to finish the job just before Christmas of 1929. This was perfectly timed as James intended to spend the festive season in Perth with a female friend. He hired an off-sider named Doug Bell to assist him, whom he ultimately sacked a few months later. In September 1929, 30-year-old George Lloyd had arrived in the Merchison area after a long and arduous drive from his hometown of Adelaide, South Australia. This was an epic journey at the time, as there were no constructed roads and all travellers had to take their own supplies and fuel. George was a tall, fit young man with fair hair, who was married with two children. A motor mechanic by trade, he had headed to the Western Australian Outback after struggling to find work in Adelaide and was prepared to tackle any kind of job. He soon accepted a position as James Ryan's new off-sider, and to celebrate, James started on a drinking bender.
这将需要大约四个月的繁重工作，这意味着詹姆斯预定在 1929 年圣诞节前夕刚好完成工作。时机非常完美，因为詹姆斯打算和一个女性朋友在珀斯度过节日。他雇了一个名叫道格·贝尔（Doug Bell）的助手来协助他，几个月后他最终解雇了他。1929 年 9 月，30 岁的乔治·劳埃德在经历了从他的家乡南澳大利亚州阿德莱德出发的长途跋涉后，抵达了默奇森地区。当时这是一次史诗般的旅程，因为没有修建好的道路，所有旅行者都必须携带自己的补给和燃料。乔治是一个身材高大、健康的年轻人，金发碧眼，已婚并育有两个孩子。作为一名汽车修理工，他在阿德莱德难以找到工作后前往西澳大利亚内陆，并准备应对任何类型的工作。他很快接受了詹姆斯·瑞安的新助手职位，为了庆祝，詹姆斯开始酗酒狂欢。
George abstained, as he didn't drink alcohol. Snowy Rolls had also been working at Nandi station around the same time that he resigned in early December 1929. He'd heard that James Ryan had sacked his previous off-sider Doug Bell and was looking for a replacement. Snowy, unaware that the position had already been filled, set off to take on the job. On December 6, he drove out to Camel station looking for James, only to be told he had passed through two weeks earlier on his way to Perth to stock up on supplies. Knowing that James was a heavy drinker, Snowy predicted he wouldn't have yet made it past the pub at the Wheatbelt town of Boracopin and headed there in search of him. Driving his old Hupmobile, Snowy only made it as far as the 100-mile post on the rabbit-proof fence before his vehicle broke down. He decided to walk to a rain shed located at the 96-mile point and wait for James or another traveller to pass through.
乔治戒酒了，因为他不喝酒。斯诺伊·罗尔斯也大约在同一时间在南迪站工作，他在 1929 年 12 月初辞职。他听说詹姆斯·瑞安解雇了他以前的助手道格·贝尔，并正在寻找替代者。斯诺伊不知道这个职位已经有人了，便出发去接替这份工作。12 月 6 日，他开车去骆驼站寻找詹姆斯，却被告知他在两周前就已经路过那里，前往珀斯囤积物资。由于知道詹姆斯是个酒鬼，斯诺伊预测他还没能穿过产粮小镇博拉科平（Boracopin）的酒吧，于是朝那里寻找他。斯诺伊开着他那辆旧胡普莫obile（Hupmobile）汽车，只开到了防兔栅栏上的 100 英里邮标处，他的车就抛锚了。他决定步行到位于 96 英里处的雨棚，等待詹姆斯或其他旅行者路过。
When Snowy arrived at the shed, he found a noisy party in full swing. Those in attendance included an acquaintance by the name of George Ritchie, who was in charge of Camel station and responsible for keeping the buildings and equipment in working order. James Ryan and George Lloyd were also there. Like James, George Ritchie was a big drinker and his wild drunken behaviour had put him under the dog act, which meant he was banned from all the pubs in the region. It turned out that the trio had been travelling along the rabbit-proof fence, making their way through a stash of booze they'd purchased. George Lloyd was the only sober one. Snowy was disappointed that James Ryan had already found a new off-sider, but was grateful for the company and for a lift back to Camel station. He helped James and George Ritchie finish their booze and the four camped at the rain shed overnight.
当斯诺伊到达棚子时，他发现了一个正在热闹进行的派对。出席的人包括一个名叫乔治·里奇（George Ritchie）的熟人，他负责骆驼站，并负责保持建筑物和设备的完好工作状态。詹姆斯·瑞安和乔治·劳埃德也在那里。和詹姆斯一样，乔治·里奇也是个大酒鬼，他疯狂的醉酒行为让他受到了“禁酒令”的约束，这意味着他被禁止进入该地区的所有酒吧。事实证明，这三人一直沿着防兔栅栏旅行，消耗着他们买的一大批酒。乔治·劳埃德是唯一一个保持清醒的人。斯诺伊很失望地发现詹姆斯·瑞安已经找到了新助手，但对有伴侣以及搭便车回骆驼站感到感激。他帮助詹姆斯和乔治·里奇喝完了酒，四个人在雨棚里露营过夜。
The next morning of December 7, 1929, both James Ryan and George Ritchie were too hungover to drive. So George Lloyd drove James in his Dodge and Snowy drove George Ritchie in George's truck. Late in the afternoon, the convoy rolled into Camel station, where they all camped the night. The following day, Snowy, James and George Lloyd loaded up the Dodge and headed to James's camp at Chale Boar. During the evening, James entertained the men by singing, while George Lloyd played along on his brand new accordion. On December 9, the trio drove to the 100-mile post to pick up Snowy's broken-down hub mobile. They brought it back to Camel station and left it in the shed there before returning to Chale Boar. The next day, the manager of Nandi station, Herman Bogle, drove to Chale Boar to check on the progress James Ryan had made to the fence.
第二天（1929 年 12 月 7 日），詹姆斯·瑞安和乔治·里奇都宿醉未醒，无法开车。于是乔治·劳埃德开着他的道奇车载着詹姆斯，斯诺伊开着乔治的卡车载着乔治·里奇。傍晚时分，车队驶入骆驼站，他们都在那里露营过夜。第二天，斯诺伊、詹姆斯和乔治·劳埃德把道奇车装满，前往詹姆斯在查莱博尔（Chale Boar）的营地。傍晚时分，詹姆斯唱歌娱乐大家，而乔治·劳埃德则用他崭新的手风琴伴奏。12 月 9 日，三人驱车前往 100 英里邮标处去接斯诺伊抛锚的胡普莫obile车。他们把它带回骆驼站，并把它留在那里的棚子里，然后返回查莱博尔。第二天，南迪站经理赫尔曼·博格尔开车去查莱博尔检查詹姆斯·瑞安栅栏建设的进展情况。
When he arrived, Snowy was the only one there. He explained that James and George Lloyd were out in the scrub, cutting the skyline for the fence. Satisfied that the work was progressing, Herman headed back to Nandi. The following day of December 11, a mineral prospector named James Yates decided to camp the night at Watson's Gate, another stopping point along the rabbit-crew fence. There, he noticed James Ryan's Dodge parked at the gate, loaded up with supplies. Mr Yates knew both the James and Snowy well, and he soon spotted Snowy drinking some water. Snowy told him that James was a few kilometers west in the bush at Yalinga Boar, collecting timber to build a yard. That evening, Snowy left in the Dodge, heading north.
当他到达时，斯诺伊是唯一的在那里的一个人。他解释说詹姆斯和乔治·劳埃德在灌木丛里，为栅栏砍伐地平线。赫尔曼对工作进展感到满意，便回到了南迪。第二天（12 月 11 日），一个名叫詹姆斯·海茨（James Yates）的矿产勘探者决定在防兔栅栏的另一个中途停留点沃森门（Watson's Gate）露营过夜。在那里，他注意到詹姆斯·瑞安的道奇车停在大门旁，装满了物资。海茨先生对詹姆斯和斯诺伊都很熟悉，他很快发现斯诺伊在喝水。斯诺伊告诉他，詹姆斯在西边的灌木丛里的亚林加博尔（Yalinga Boar），正在收集木材来建造一个院子。那天晚上，斯诺伊开着道奇车向北驶去。
This struck Mr Yates' odd. If James was out west as Snowy had said, then it didn't make sense that Snowy had driven away in a different direction. Mr Yates decided to investigate the next morning. He followed the Dodge's tire tracks and found that Snowy had made his own route through the scrub, purposely avoiding Camel Station. His tracks eventually linked up with Chally Boar, indicating that he never went to Yalinga Boar, where he claimed James Ryan was looking for timber. Mr Yates was confused as to why Snowy had lied. He drove over to Camel Station to discuss the matter with George Ritchie, who was an old maid of his. The two men were puzzled.
这让海茨先生觉得很奇怪。如果詹姆斯像斯诺伊说的那样在西边，那么斯诺伊朝相反方向开走就说不通了。海茨先生决定第二天进行调查。他顺着道奇车的轮胎痕迹发现斯诺伊在灌木丛中开辟了自己的路线，刻意避开了骆驼站。他的痕迹最终与查利博尔相连，这表明他从未去过他声称詹姆斯·瑞安正在寻找木材的亚林加博尔。海茨先生对斯诺伊为什么要撒谎感到困惑。他开车去骆驼站与老熟人乔治·里奇讨论这件事。这两个人感到迷惑不解。
They wondered whether James and Snowy had perhaps discovered gold in the bush and were trying to keep it a secret. Eight days later, on December 21, Nandi station manager Herman Bogle arrived at Chally Boar. The fence was expected to be nearing completion. However, Herman discovered no one at the job site. James Ryan, George Lloyd and Snowy Rolls were missing. Herman assumed they must have gone to Barra Coppin, perhaps for a Christmas bender. He searched the site and found a crowbar and a couple of shovels, which he recognized as belonging to James. Herman was annoyed as James owed him some money and had also borrowed his compass and steel surveying tape, which Herman wanted back.
他们想知道詹姆斯和斯诺伊是否在丛林中发现了黄金并试图将其保密。八天后的 12 月 21 日，南迪站经理赫尔曼·博格尔抵达查利博尔。栅栏预计将接近完工。然而，赫尔曼发现工作现场没有人。詹姆斯·瑞安、乔治·劳埃德和斯诺伊·罗尔斯都不见了。赫尔曼推测他们一定去了巴拉科平，可能是为了过圣诞节痛饮一番。他在现场搜查，发现了一根撬棍和几把铁锹，他认出这些都属于詹姆斯。赫尔曼很生气，因为詹姆斯还欠他一些钱，还借了他的罗盘和钢制测量带，赫尔曼想要拿回这些东西。
Herman returned to Chally Boar three days later to check if James had returned. But it appeared as though he and the others had cleared out for good, leaving the fencing job unfinished. Arthur Upfield was born in England in 1890 and by age 20 had been sent to Australia by his father in the hopes that he would prove himself as a man. He spent several years working in the outback, accepting whatever jobs came his way, including boundary rider, shearers cork, fur trapper, bullock driver and opal gouger. Arthur was a keen rider who spent his spare time penning manuscripts. His first novel, a thriller titled The House of Cain, was published in London in 1928 and his publisher quickly commissioned him to write three more novels. After completing his second book, Arthur travelled to Mount Magnon, where he secured a job as fence runner and camel breaker at Camel Station. As the southern boundary rider, he was responsible for the portion of the number one rabbit-proof fence that stretched 163 miles south from Camel Station down to Barakopin.
三天后，赫曼回到查利野猪客栈，查看詹姆斯是否已经回来。但看起来他和另外几个人已经彻底离开了，留下了尚未完工的围栏工作。亚瑟·厄普菲尔德于1890年出生于英国，20岁时被父亲送到澳大利亚，希望他能证明自己是一个真正的男人。他在内陆度过了好几年，接受了所有找上门的工作，包括边界骑手、剪毛工、皮草猎人、牛车夫和蛋白石采掘工。亚瑟是个狂热的骑手，闲暇时喜欢埋头写作手稿。他的第一部小说是一部名为《凯恩之屋》的惊悚小说，1928年在伦敦出版，他的出版商很快又委托他再写三部小说。完成第二本书后，亚瑟前往芒特马农，在骆驼站找到了一份围栏巡视员和骆驼驯马师的工作。作为南部的边界骑手，他负责从骆驼站向南延伸163英里一直到巴拉科平的头号防兔网的那段路。
It was during this time that he met Snowy Rolls, who was working as a casual station hand, fox hunter and horse breaker in the area. By late 1929, Arthur had heard Snowy was constructing a stretcher fence line in the northwest with the James Ryan and George Lloyd. On December 23, Arthur arrived in the town of Ewen Me, where he spotted Snowy Rolls on the steps of the Ewen Me Hotel. Snowy informed Arthur that James Ryan had quit the fencing job because he owed station manager Herman Bogle too much money. Snowy, George and James had left the area and travelled to Mount Magnon, where the latter decided to stay. James let Snowy borrow his dodge to drive to Ewen Me for Christmas. Snowy had since picked up temporary work at the local hotel, where he also stayed. After crossing paths with Arthur Upfield, Snowy ran into Arthur's mate and boundary rider counterpart Lance Madison.
正是在这段时间里，他遇到了斯诺维·罗尔斯，后者当时在该地区担任临时牧场杂工、狐狸猎人和驯马师。到1929年底，亚瑟听说斯诺维正与詹姆斯·赖安和乔治·劳埃德在西北部建造一条担架围栏线。12月23日，亚瑟抵达尤恩梅镇，在那里他看到斯诺维·罗尔斯站在尤恩梅酒店的台阶上。斯诺维告诉亚瑟，詹姆斯·赖安因为欠牧场经理赫曼·博格太多钱而辞去了修围栏的工作。斯诺维、乔治和詹姆斯已经离开该地区前往芒特马农，后者决定留在那儿。詹姆斯让斯诺维借走他的道奇汽车，以便开车去尤恩梅过圣诞节。斯诺维此后一直在当地的一家酒店找了份临时工作，他也住在那儿。在与亚瑟·厄普菲尔德擦肩而过后，斯诺维遇到了亚瑟的朋友兼边界骑手同行兰斯·麦迪逊。
He told Lance that James had sold him the dodge for £75, or the equivalent of about $9000 in today's currency. Neither Lance nor Arthur found Snowy's comments suspicious and didn't mention his conflicting stories to one another. They both knew he was in the market for a new vehicle given his hub mobile had died and that he had family in Perth who had sent him money in the past. Additionally, they knew how much James Ryan loved to drink and thought he'd be willing to sell the shirt off his back in order to afford more booze. It also made sense to Arthur and Lance that George Lloyd could have stayed in Mount Magnon to keep an eye on his friend. Days later, on December 26, a prospector named Ted May bumped into Snowy driving the dodge in Ewen Me. Ted recognised the vehicle as he had worked for James Ryan earlier that year. Surprised to see Snowy driving it, he asked after James to which Snowy replied.
他告诉兰斯，詹姆斯以75英镑的价格把道奇车卖给了他，相当于今天大约9000美元的价值。兰斯和亚瑟都没有觉得斯诺维的话有什么可疑，也没有互相提及他那相互矛盾的说辞。他们都知道，鉴于他的哈勃汽车已经报废，他一直在寻找一辆新车，而且他在珀斯有家人，过去曾给他寄过钱。此外，他们知道詹姆斯·赖安有多爱喝酒，认为他为了买更多酒，甚至愿意把身上的衬衣都卖掉。亚瑟和兰斯还觉得，乔治·劳埃德可能为了照顾朋友而留在了芒特马农，这也在情理之中。几天后的12月26日，一位名叫特德·梅的探矿者在尤恩梅偶遇了开着道奇车的斯诺维。特德认出了这辆车，因为他当年早些时候曾为詹姆斯·赖安工作过。看到斯诺维开着这辆车，他感到很惊讶，便打听詹姆斯的下落，斯诺维回答说。
Last I heard he was in Mount Magnon, he was talking about going up to Waluna so I expect that's where he is now. I bought the truck off him for £80. Snowy continued working at the Ewen Me Hotel until February 10, 1930 after which he returned to the Rabbitproof Fence where he worked as a freelance fox hunter and dog trapper. He mostly stayed in the Ewen Me, Dromedary Hills area but occasionally ventured further afield. One day he bumped into James Ryan's former off-sider, Doug Bell, who asked whether James was in town. Snowy said the last time he had seen James was in Nandi and he believed he was heading to Boracopin from there. He told Doug that James had owed him £30 which he didn't have so Snowy had struck up a deal to clear the debt, paying James £40 in exchange for the dodge. In April 1930, Snowy made his way to the Fountain Camp which was where he met Louis Caron.
我最后一次听到他的消息时他在芒特马农，他当时在谈论去瓦卢纳的事，所以我预计他现在就在那里。我花80英镑从他手里买下了这辆卡车。斯诺维在尤恩梅酒店继续工作到1930年2月10日，之后他回到了防兔网，在那里担任自由职业狐狸猎人和狗捕手。他主要呆在尤恩梅和德罗默代里山脉一带，但也偶尔去更远的地方。一天，他偶遇了詹姆斯·赖安的前助手道格·贝尔，道格问詹姆斯是否在镇上。斯诺维说他最后一次见到詹姆斯是在南迪，他相信詹姆斯正从那里前往博拉科平。他告诉道格，詹姆斯欠他30英镑却没有还，于是斯诺维做了一笔交易来抵清这笔债务，向詹姆斯支付了40英镑换取了道奇车。1930年4月，斯诺维来到了喷泉营地，并在那里遇到了路易斯·卡隆。
Detective Manning was now certain that Louis Caron had met with foul play after leaving the Fountain Camp with Snowy roles and he continued his investigation into the New Zealanders disappearance and suspected death. During Detective Manning's inquiries he also learned another interesting detail. According to Arthur Upfield and a few of his associates, Arthur had been working on his fourth manuscript in the months leading up to James Ryan and George Lloyd's disappearance. It was a follow-up to his second novel, The Barracky Mystery, which focused on a murder investigation conducted by a fictional character named Detective Inspector Napoleon Bonaparte, known simply as Boney. The character of Detective Boni was based on a friend of Arthur's, an indigenous man named Leon whose mother had been murdered when he was a baby. Consequently, Leon had been raised on a Queensland mission and was later employed as a tracker with the Queensland police. The Barracky Mystery experienced a moderate success and Arthur Upfield planned to write more novels in the Detective Boney series. By mid-1929 he started brainstorming ideas for his next book.
曼宁侦探现在确信，路易斯·卡隆在与斯诺维·罗尔斯离开喷泉营地后遭遇了不测，他继续对这名新西兰人的失踪和疑似死亡展开调查。在曼宁侦探调查期间，他还了解到另一个有趣的细节。根据亚瑟·厄普菲尔德及其实几位同伴的说法，在詹姆斯·赖安和乔治·劳埃德失踪前的几个月里，亚瑟一直在创作他的第四部手稿。这是他的第二部小说《巴拉克神秘事件》的续集，故事聚焦于由一个虚构角色拿破仑·波拿巴侦探（简称为博尼）所进行的谋杀案调查。侦探博尼这个角色是以亚瑟的一位朋友为原型的，那是一个名叫里昂的土著人，他的母亲在他还是个婴儿时就被谋杀。因此，里昂在昆士兰的一个教会长大，后来受雇担任昆士兰警方的追踪者。《巴拉克神秘事件》获得了适度的成功，亚瑟·厄普菲尔德计划在博尼侦探系列中写更多的小说。到1929年中期，他开始为自己的下一本书构思点子。
As Arthur understood it, a murder mystery required three key plot points, the discovery of a corpse, followed by a detective beginning their investigation and then finally, the killer being identified and arrested. Wanting to be original, Arthur questioned whether the first plot point was even necessary to his story. Without a victim's body, Detective Boni would have to prove a murder had been committed, along with how and by whom, resulting in a unique take on an otherwise predictable narrative. While the idea was very attractive to Arthur, he quickly realised the practical difficulties. The biggest problem was how the killer could dispose of a body so thoroughly as to leave no trace. Most real-life murderers had failed to do so, despite all their ingenuity. Arthur contemplated the use of a crematorium or bath of corrosive acid, but ruled them out as they weren't resources that the average person in his fictionalised, though realistic, Australian outback story would have access to. One night in the winter of 1929, Arthur was playing cards with George Ritchie at Camel Station Homestead, when he asked George for a good way of completely destroying a human body without leaving any trace.
在亚瑟看来，一个谋杀悬疑故事需要三个关键情节：发现尸体，接着是侦探开始调查，最后是凶手被识别并逮捕。为了保持独创性，亚瑟质疑第一个情节对他的故事是否真的必要。如果没有受害者的尸体，博尼侦探将不得不证明谋杀确实发生过，以及是如何发生的、又是谁干的，从而对原本可预测的叙事带来独特的诠释。虽然这个想法对亚瑟很有吸引力，但他很快意识到了实际困难。最大的问题是凶手如何能如此彻底地处理尸体而不留下一丝痕迹。尽管绞尽脑汁，现实生活中的大多数凶手都未能做到这一点。亚瑟考虑过使用火化炉或腐蚀酸浴，但由于它们不是他的虚构却又现实的澳大利亚内陆故事中的普通人能够轻易获取的资源，因而被他排除了。1929年冬天的一个晚上，亚瑟在骆驼站宅邸和乔治·里奇打牌，当时他向乔治请教彻底消灭一具人类尸体且不留任何痕迹的好方法。
George suggested the killer lure the victim into the bush, shoot him and then burn the body, clothes and all. After a few days, the killer could return to the bush with a sieve and sift through the ashes to find any metal parts and remaining bone fragments. The metal objects could be thrown down a well, while the bones could be crushed to dust using a dolly pot, a manual device used to crush rock specimens when peering for gold and other minerals. The killer could then shoot and burn a couple of kangaroos on top of the same ash pile as a disguise. Arthur marvelled at the simplicity of his friend's method, but viewed it as too perfect. If there was no evidence of a corpse, Arthur questioned how Detective Boney could prove to a judge or jury that a murder had even been committed. The police and courts would require some identifiable remains before they could charge a suspect with murder. Arthur decided that the killer would have to make a mistake, as there needed to be evidence, no matter how small.
乔治建议凶手把受害者引诱到丛林里，开枪打死他，然后连衣服带尸体一起烧掉。几天后，凶手可以拿着筛子回到丛林里，在灰烬中筛找任何金属部件和残留的骨头碎片。金属物品可以扔进井里，而骨头可以使用矿石捣碎罐研磨成粉，这是一种用于在寻找黄金和其他矿物质时粉碎岩石标本的手动设备。然后，凶手可以在同一堆灰烬上面枪杀并烧毁几只袋鼠来进行掩饰。亚瑟对朋友这种方法的简单性赞叹不已，但又认为它过于完美。如果没有尸体的证据，亚瑟质疑博尼侦探如何向法官或陪审团证明谋杀甚至已经发生。警方和法院在指控嫌疑人谋杀之前，需要一些可辨认的遗骸。亚瑟决定，凶手必须犯错，因为无论多么微小，必须有证据留下。
He offered to pay George Ritchie one pound, or the equivalent of around 120 Australian dollars in today's currency, if he could identify an error in the killer's disposal plan. George Ritchie was determined to find a solution and reap the reward. A few weeks later, he ran into Snowy Rolls, who was on his motorbike near Camel Station. George was carrying a rifle, and without providing any context, he asked, Hey Snow, if I was to shoot you stone dead, drag your body over to that dead scrub, burn it thoroughly, then come back tomorrow with a sieve and go through the ashes for the bones and the metal objects on your clothes. Dump the metal objects down a well, and dolly your bones to dust. How could my crime be discovered? Snowy looked afraid and rode away on his motorbike without responding. He arrived at Camel Station, where he found Arthur Upfield and told him about the odd exchange.
他提出如果乔治·里奇能在凶手的处理计划中挑出一个错误，就付给他一英镑，相当于今天大约120澳元的价值。乔治·里奇决心找到解决方案并获得奖励。几周后，他遇到了骑着摩托车路过骆驼站附近的斯诺维·罗尔斯。乔治拿着一把步枪，在没有任何背景铺垫的情况下，他问：“嘿，斯诺，如果我要把你一枪毙命，把你的尸体拖到那片枯死的灌木丛里，彻底烧掉，然后明天带着筛子回来，在灰烬里搜寻骨头和你衣服上的金属物品。把金属物品扔进井里，再把你的骨头捣成粉末。我的罪行怎么会被发现呢？”斯诺维看起来很害怕，一言不发地骑着摩托车走了。他来到骆驼站，找到了亚瑟·厄普菲尔德，并向他讲述了这个奇怪的对话。
He feared George Ritchie had gone mad and wanted to shoot him. Amused, Arthur explained his new Detective Boney project and the offer he had made to George to come up with a flaw in his otherwise perfect murder scenario. Arthur openly discussed his conundrum to others, and it became a talking point during a small party held at Camel Station in October 1929. Everyone in attendance, including Snowy, tried to come up with a solution. Despite their best efforts, they were unable to find fault in George Ritchie's idea. Arthur started to give up. Then, one morning, while he was preoccupied with his camels, he had an epiphany. His fictional killer would not be aware that his victim had a small silver plate in his head that was used to repair a war wound. When the killer shot the victim in the head, Arthur decided the little silver plate would be sent flying to be eventually found by Detective Boney.
他担心乔治·里奇疯了，想开枪打他。亚瑟觉得很有趣，便向他解释了自己新的博尼侦探项目，以及他向乔治提出的悬赏，希望能找出他那本该完美的谋杀设想中的漏洞。亚瑟公开向其他人讨论他的难题，这成了1929年10月在骆驼站举行的一个小型派对上的谈资。所有在场的人，包括斯诺维，都试图找出解决方案。尽管他们付出了最大努力，却无法在乔治·里奇的想法中找到任何漏洞。亚瑟开始放弃了。然后，一天早晨，当他正忙于照顾他的骆驼时，他突然灵光一闪。他的虚构凶手不会知道受害者的头部有一块小银片，那是用来修复战争伤口的。当凶手击中受害者的头部时，亚瑟决定这块小银片会被震飞，并最终被博尼侦探发现。
Boney would then be able to deduce that the missing victim was dead. Arthur also fine-tuned the disposal of any remaining metal fragments with the body, so that instead of throwing them down a disused well, his fictional killer would dissolve them in nitric acid, small jars of which were available at the stations in the area. The plot was finally complete. Arthur began writing the manuscript, which he titled The Sands of Windy. To Detective Manning, it didn't appear to be a coincidence that Louis Caron had been disposed of in the same manner described in Arthur's upcoming novel. Armed with this new information, he returned to Nandi with Constable Hearn, and the duo drove down to James Ryan's former campsite at Chully Boar. It was a remote area 800 metres west of the Rabbitproof Fence that was very rarely used. At the camp, they discovered the remnants of eight fire sites, similar to those where Louis Caron's remains were found. The officers scoured the ashes and found some metal eyelets from pairs of shoes, metal parts from an accordion, and various bone fragments that were badly burned and broken.
这样博尼就能推断出失踪的受害者已经死亡。亚瑟还微调了随尸体一起残留的金属碎片的处理方式，使得虚构的凶手不再是将它们扔进废弃的井里，而是用硝酸将它们溶解，该地区的工作站里就有这种小瓶装的硝酸。情节终于完成了。亚瑟开始撰写手稿，他将其命名为《温迪之沙》。对曼宁侦探来说，路易斯·卡隆以亚瑟即将出版的小说中所描述的相同方式被处理掉，这似乎并非巧合。带着这些新信息，他和赫恩警员回到了南迪，两人开车前往詹姆斯·赖安在查利野猪的前营地。这是一个距离防兔网以西800米的偏远地区，极少有人使用。在营地里，他们发现了八处火堆的残余，类似于发现路易斯·卡隆遗骸的地方。警官们仔细搜查了灰烬，找到了一些鞋子的金属孔眼、手风琴的金属部件，以及各种严重烧焦和破碎的骨头碎片。
The bone fragments were so damaged that it was impossible to determine whether they were human or animal. However, the presence of the shoe eyelets and accordion pieces convinced the officers there was a high probability they were human and belonged to James Ryan and George Lloyd. Had the men chosen to vacate the camp without their shoes or George's accordion, they would have simply left these items behind instead of burning them. Furthermore, it made no sense for them to depart into the dense bushland without their shoes. As Snowy Rolls was the last man seen with the James and George and was now driving James's Dodge, Detective Manning concluded that Snowy had likely murdered both men as well as Louis Caron. Although it was unlikely that Snowy was motivated to commit the murders by Arthur Upfield's fictional plot, there was a high chance the novel had provided the inspiration. As it was highly improbable that all three men had been killed in separate fits of rage, Detective Manning determined that the deaths were calculated and had been financially motivated. In early March 1931, Detective Manning and Constable Herne travelled with Constable Thomas Penn from the Maker Thera police to Hillview Station looking for Snowy Rolls.
骨头碎片受损严重，以至于无法确定它们是人类的还是动物的。然而，鞋眼和手风琴部件的存在使警官们确信它们极有可能是人类的，并且属于詹姆斯·赖安和乔治·劳埃德。如果这几个人选择在没有鞋子或乔治的手风琴的情况下离开营地，他们本会直接把这些物品留下，而不是把它们烧掉。此外，在没有鞋子的情况下深入密集的灌木林毫无道理。由于斯诺维·罗尔斯是最后一个与詹姆斯和乔治在一起且现在开着詹姆斯的道奇车的人，曼宁侦探推断斯诺维很可能谋杀了这两个人以及路易斯·卡隆。尽管斯诺维不太可能是受亚瑟·厄普菲尔德虚构情节的驱使而犯罪，但这部小说极有可能是提供了灵感。鉴于这三个人不太可能都在各自的愤怒发作中被杀，曼宁侦探判定这些死亡是蓄意谋杀且出于经济动机。1931年3月初，曼宁侦探和赫恩警员与来自马卡萨拉警局的托马斯·佩恩警员一起前往希尔维尤站寻找斯诺维·罗尔斯。
After learning he was stationed at an out-camp several miles from the Hillview homestead, the officers dressed undercover in worn Bushman's clothing and made their way to the camp. When they arrived, Snowy wasn't at his hut, so they kept a discreet presence. The following afternoon at 2.30, Snowy drove up in a lightweight horse-drawn cart known as a Sulky. Detective Manning was a short distance away in the bush, but Constable's Herne and Penn were sitting in their car nearby. They watched as Snowy unharnessed the horses from the Sulky and led them away. The Constables approached the cart and found a .22 bore rifle in the back. When Snowy returned to the Sulky after a short absence, Constable Herne was casually examining the rifle. At this point, Detective Manning arrived on the scene.
在得知他驻扎在距离希尔维尤宅邸数英里外的一个前哨营地后，警官们便换上了破旧的丛林人便服，秘密前往该营地。他们到达时，斯诺维不在他的小屋里，于是他们保持了谨慎的潜伏。第二天下午2点30分，斯诺维驾驶一辆被称为“苏尔基”的轻型马车驶来。曼宁侦探在不远处的灌木丛中，而赫恩和佩恩警员则坐在附近的车里。他们看着斯诺维把马从苏尔基车上解开并把它们牵走。警员们走近马车，在车厢后部发现了一支.22口径的步枪。当斯诺维短暂离开后返回马车时，赫恩警员正漫不经心地检查着那支步枪。就在这时，曼宁侦探来到了现场。
To his surprise, he recognized Snowy Rolls as none other than John Thomas Smith, a convicted criminal who was wanted for escaping from Dalwala New Prison in 1928. He asked Snowy how long he had been going by the name Rolls. Snowy, who evidently also recognized Detective Manning, replied, You know very well who I am, and if I had known who you were, you wouldn't have got me so easily. The officers said they were looking for Louis Caron, James Ryan and George Lloyd, all three of whom were last seen in Snowy's company. When Snowy was asked where he'd gotten the Dodge Utility truck that was in the shed, he explained he'd purchased it from James Ryan. Snowy let the officers into his hut, where they found two loaded .32 bore rifles. Detective Manning asked Snowy if everything in the hut was his, to which he said yes, except for the rifles, the sewing machine and the gramophone.
令他惊讶的是，他认出斯诺维·罗尔斯不是别人，正是约翰·托马斯·史密斯，一名因在1928年从达尔瓦拉新监狱越狱而被通缉的罪犯。他问斯诺维叫罗尔斯这个名字多久了。显然也认出了曼宁侦探的斯诺维回答道：“你很清楚我是谁，如果我早知道你是谁，你就不会这么轻易抓到我了。”警官们说他们在寻找路易斯·卡隆、詹姆斯·赖安和乔治·劳埃德，这三人最后一次出现都是和斯诺维在一起。当被问及棚子里那辆道奇多功能卡车是从哪里弄来的时，斯诺维解释说是从詹姆斯·赖安那里买的。斯诺维让警官们进了他的小屋，他们在那里发现了两支上膛的.32口径步枪。曼宁侦探问斯诺维小屋里的东西是不是全都是他的，斯诺维说是的，除了步枪、缝纫机和留声机。
The officers gave Snowy permission to cook himself some food while they searched the hut. In the drawer of the sewing machine, they found a pair of expensive hair clippers, which Snowy claimed to have bought from a traveling salesman. One of the officers found a parcel wrapped in newspaper sitting high on a shelf. When he reached for it, Snowy said, Where the hell did you get that? I know nothing about it. Inside the parcel was a wristwatch, three shirts, a watch chain, a pair of scissors and a razor marked as being made in New Zealand. The officers also searched the Dodge and found an open-faced watch that Snowy claimed was already there when he purchased the vehicle from James Ryan. As there was an outstanding warrant for Snowy's arrest from the Dalwala New Jailbreak, he was informed that he would be returned to custody.
警官们允许斯诺维自己做些吃的，同时他们搜查了小屋。在缝纫机的抽屉里，他们发现了一把昂贵的理发推剪，斯诺维声称这是从一个旅行推销员那里买的。其中一名警官在书架高处发现了一个用报纸包着的包裹。当他伸手去拿时，斯诺维说：“你们到底从哪儿弄来的这东西？我对此一无所知。”包裹里面是一块手表、三件衬衫、一条表链、一把剪刀和一把标有新西兰制造的剃须刀。警官们还搜查了道奇车，发现了一块表盘外露的手表，斯诺维声称他从詹姆斯·赖安那里买下这辆车时，这块表就已经在车里了。由于斯诺维身上有来自达尔瓦拉新监狱越狱案的未执行逮捕令，他被告知将被押回羁押所。
After finishing his meal, he asked for permission to change into a blue surge suit. Detective Manning pointed out that this was unnecessary given the long, dusty ride ahead, but eventually agreed. The four men then drove 130km to the Mika Thara police station, where Snowy Rolls, aka John Thomas Smith, was returned to custody. John Thomas Smith was born in Western Australia on August 8, 1905, to parents Ernest and Catherine. He was one of seven children and the family lived in a rented house in the suburb of North Perth. As a child, John had white blonde hair, which earned him the lifelong nickname of Snowy. Although intelligent, he was a lazy student and prone to petty theft. By the age of 11, he was already known to the police and had appeared in children's court three times.
吃完饭后，他请求换上一套蓝色哔叽西装。曼宁侦探指出，考虑到接下来漫长而尘土飞扬的路程，这样做没有必要，但最终还是同意了。随后，四人开车130公里前往米卡萨拉警察局，斯诺维·罗尔斯（又名约翰·托马斯·史密斯）被重新收押。约翰·托马斯·史密斯于1905年8月8日出生于西澳大利亚，父母是欧内斯特和凯瑟琳。他是七个孩子中的一个，全家住在北珀斯郊区的一栋租来的房子里。小时候，约翰有一头白金色的头发，这给他带来了伴随一生的绰号“斯诺维”（意为雪白）。虽然很聪明，但他是个懒惰的学生，容易顺手牵羊。11岁时，他已经被警方熟知，并曾三次出庭少年法庭。
Snowy left school at age 14 and worked sporadically as an unskilled labourer. He was almost always broke and continued to get in trouble with the law. By the time he was 20 years old, Snowy had accumulated a string of fines, predominantly for theft and unlawful possession. He acquired a motorcycle and whenever it needed a new seat, he simply stole one from someone else's bike and installed it on his own. In April 1926, Snowy robbed two employees from the WA Boot Manufacturing Company as they returned from the National Bank, carrying a briefcase full of cash for the weekly paychecks. The briefcase contained £333, which would amount to approximately $40,000 in today's currency. Snowy was arrested, found guilty of the crime and sentenced to two and a half years imprisonment with hard labour. He was released less than two years later on February 2, 1928 at the age of 22.
斯诺维14岁离开学校，零星地做着非技术杂工。他几乎总是身无分文，并继续惹上法律麻烦。到20岁时，斯诺维已经积累了一长串罚款，主要针对盗窃和非法占有。他买了一辆摩托车，每当它需要一个新座位时，他就会直接从别人的自行车上偷一个并安装在自己的车上。1926年4月，斯诺维抢劫了西澳靴业制造公司的两名员工，当时他们正从国家银行回来，提着装满每周薪水现金的公文包。公文包里有333英镑，相当于今天大约40,000美元的价值。斯诺维被捕，被判犯有此罪，并被判处两年半硬劳役监禁。他在不到两年后的1928年2月2日获释，当时年仅22岁。
Five months later, he broke into a cooperative store in the small Wheatbelt town of Nungaran and stole some food, a suitcase and clothing. Four days after that, he and another man burgled a store in the remote town of Dalwollenew taking £7, the equivalent of around $840 Australian dollars today, as well as an assortment of goods and clothing. The police found a can of petrol and jellignite left behind at the scene. It appeared as though the culprits had intended to blow up the shops safe, but abandoned their plan at the last minute. Snowy and his accomplice, Thomas Wilson, were found hiding in the bush and were placed under arrest. They were taken to Dalwollenew, where they were charged and held in the wooden lock-up behind the police station. On July 23, Detective Manning was dispatched from Perth to appear at their committal hearing before the district magistrate, during which both men were committed to stand trial in Perth. The following day of July 24, Detective Manning returned to Perth to organise secure transport for the two thieves.
五个月后，他闯入小麦带小镇农加兰的一家合作社商店，偷了一些食物、一个手提箱和衣服。四天后，他和另一个人在偏远小镇达尔沃勒纽的一家商店行窃，盗走了7英镑，相当于今天大约840澳元，以及各种商品和衣物。警方在现场发现了一罐汽油和凝胶炸药。看起来这群罪犯曾打算炸毁商店的保险箱，但在最后一刻放弃了计划。斯诺维和他的同伙托马斯·威尔逊被发现藏在灌木丛中并被逮捕。他们被带到达尔沃勒纽，在那里被起诉并关押在警察局后面的木质拘留所里。7月23日，曼宁侦探从珀斯被派往出席地方法官主持的交付审判听证会，在此期间两名男子都被交付在珀斯受审。第二天7月24日，曼宁侦探返回珀斯，为这两名小偷组织安全的运输。
That evening, an officer entered Snowy and Wilson's cell to deliver their dinner, but the men knocked the tray into the officer's face and bolted out of the open cell door. They fled into the darkness as police brandishing rifles pursued them. Wilson was hit and injured by one of the officer's bullets, so he surrendered, while Snowy escaped into the night. The next day, the only trace that police could find of him was a report of a stolen horse. The search eventually wound down, but the warrant for Snowy's arrest remained active. Snowy soon found himself a motorcycle and made his way to the Merchison District, where he adopted the name Stanley Rolls, while continuing to go by his nickname of Snowy. With Snowy now held in the Mika Thara lock-up on account of his outstanding arrest warrant, Detective Manning questioned him about the trip he took with Louis Caron. Snowy claimed that after leaving the Fountain campsite, the two men spent the night camping at Windamara.
那天晚上，一名警官进入斯诺维和威尔逊的牢房送晚饭，但这两人把餐盘打到警官脸上，从敞开的牢房门冲了出去。他们逃进了黑暗中，持枪的警察紧追不舍。威尔逊被警察的一颗子弹击中受伤，于是他投降了，而斯诺维则逃入了黑夜。第二天，警察能找到他唯一的痕迹是一起偷马的报告。搜捕最终平息了，但针对斯诺维的逮捕令仍然有效。斯诺维很快找到了一辆摩托车，并前往默奇森区，在那里他化名为斯坦利·罗尔斯，同时继续使用他的绰号斯诺维。由于未执行的逮捕令，斯诺维现在被关押在米卡萨拉拘留所里，曼宁侦探就他与路易斯·卡隆的旅行对其实施了讯问。斯诺维声称，离开喷泉营地后，两人在温达马拉露营了一晚。
The following day, Snowy went to Painesville to cash Louis' check and pick up supplies before spending the night at the Painesville Hotel. On the third day, he returned to Windamara, where he and Louis began work shooting kangaroos. On day four, the two men travelled to Mount Magnon, where they parted company. That night, Snowy slept by the roadside and then continued on to you and me the following day. Detective Manning then questioned him about his time spent with the James Ryan and George Lloyd. Snowy claimed that after leaving Nandi Station in early December, the trio travelled to Chalibor Camp, where they stayed for several nights. On their third day there, James and George made a day trip to Nandi, and when they returned, all three men started to cut the skyline for the fence. On day four, James was having trouble with the tyres on his dodge, so Snowy rode his motorcycle to Nandi to retrieve the puncture repair kit.
第二天，斯诺维去佩恩斯维尔兑现路易斯的支票并挑选物资，然后在佩恩斯维尔酒店过夜。第三天，他返回温达马拉，他和路易斯开始在那里工作射杀袋鼠。第四天，两人前往芒特马农，在那里各奔东西。那天晚上，斯诺维睡在路边，第二天继续前往尤恩梅。曼宁侦探随后就他与詹姆斯·赖安和乔治·劳埃德共度的时间对他进行了讯问。斯诺维声称，12月初离开南迪站后，三人前往查利博尔营地，在那里住了好几个夜晚。在那里的第三天，詹姆斯和乔治去南迪进行了一日游，当他们返回时，三个人开始为围栏砍伐天际线。第四天，詹姆斯的道奇车轮胎出了问题，于是斯诺维骑着摩托车去南迪取补胎工具。
The next day, he fixed the puncture, and a man named Herman Bogle paid a visit to Chalibor. James was working on the fence about two kilometres down the track at the time and didn't see Herman, which he was relieved about, as he owed Herman quite a bit of money. Snowy, James and George stayed at Chalibor for a few more days before deciding to leave on the eighth day. When they reached the 202 Mile Gate, the dodge broke down, so they camped out on the track for the night. The following day, some men in two separate vehicles drove by, saying they were heading north. James and George decided to hitch a ride with the men, and James sold his dodge to Snowy. According to Snowy, that was the last he ever saw of either of the men. After Snowy signed his statement, he remarked,
第二天，他修好了轮胎，一个名叫赫曼·博格的人拜访了查利博尔。当时詹姆斯正在沿小路大约两公里处修围栏，没有看到赫曼，这让他松了一口气，因为他欠赫曼不少钱。斯诺维、詹姆斯和乔治在查利博尔多呆了几天，最后决定在第八天离开。当他们到达202英里门时，道奇车抛锚了，于是他们在路边露营过夜。第二天，一些开着两辆不同车辆的人开车路过，说他们正向北行驶。詹姆斯和乔治决定搭这些人的便车，詹姆斯将他的道奇车卖给了斯诺维。根据斯诺维的说法，那是他最后一次见到这两个人中的任何一个。斯诺维签署供词后，评论道：
A man must have a kink to do this sort of thing. I am sorry I did not take my old lady's advice. She wanted me to give myself up when I escaped from Darwollenu, and if I'd taken her advice, I would have had that all over by now, and would not have had this other thing to face. Manning asked what other thing he was referring to, as Snowy was only being held on his outstanding arrest warrant, and hadn't yet been charged with anything else. Snowy replied, Oh, the less said about that the better. Snowy was taken to Perth to stand trial for his original crime of breaking and entering in Darwollenu in early 1928. He was convicted and sentenced to three years in prison, giving the authorities plenty of time to continue their investigation into the disappearances of Louis Caron, James Ryan, and George Lloyd.
一个人脑子得有点毛病才会干这种事。我很遗憾没有听我老太母亲的劝告。自我从达尔沃勒纽逃出后，她就想让我自首，如果我听了她的劝告，我现在就已经把这一切都抛在脑后了，也就不用面对这另一件麻烦事了。曼宁问他指的是什么别的事，因为斯诺维当时仅凭未执行的逮捕令被关押，尚未被指控其他任何罪名。斯诺维回答说：“哦，那件事少说为妙。”斯诺维被带到珀斯，准备为他在1928年初在达尔沃勒纽犯下的入室盗窃旧罪受审。他被判定有罪并被判处三年监禁，这为主管当局继续调查路易斯·卡隆、詹姆斯·赖安和乔治·劳埃德的失踪案留出了充足的时间。
Two eminent pathologists studied the bone fragments that were discovered in the remains of the fire at the 183-mile gate. They confirmed that the non-artificial teeth were human, with one proving to be a molar tooth. Some of the smaller bones were suspected to be human finger or toe bones, although the pathologists couldn't conclusively rule out the possibility that they were from animal pores. The few skull fragments were fitted together, and it was determined they had most likely come from a Caucasian male. These skull fragments, along with the teeth, were the only decisive evidence that the fires had indeed contained human remains. On January 7, 1932, Snowy Rolls, aka John Thomas Smith, was formally charged with the murder of Louis Caron, and a mandatory coroner's inquest was ordered. On January 9, the media reported that earlier the previous year, Snowy had made two suicide attempts while in the Makathara lockup. Constable Penn told the Western Argus newspaper that he'd found Snowy attempting to hang himself in his cell, at which point Snowy also admitted that he'd tried taking strychnine, a highly toxic poison typically used as a pesticide.
两位杰出的病理学家研究了在183英里门火灾残骸中发现的骨头碎片。他们证实，那些非人工牙齿是人类的，其中一颗被证明是磨牙。一些较小的骨头被怀疑是人类的手指或脚趾骨，尽管病理学家不能确凿地排除它们来自动物毛孔的可能性。几块头骨碎片被拼合在一起，并确定它们极有可能来自一名高加索男性。这些头骨碎片以及牙齿，是火灾中确实含有残骸的唯一决定性证据。1932年1月7日，斯诺维·罗尔斯（又名约翰·托马斯·史密斯）被正式指控谋杀路易斯·卡隆，并下令进行强制性的验尸官研讯。1月9日，媒体报道称，在前一年的早些时候，斯诺维在马卡萨拉拘留所里曾两次尝试自杀。佩恩警员告诉《西澳大利亚人报》，他发现斯诺维试图在牢房里上吊自杀，此时斯诺维也承认他曾试图服用番木鳖碱，这是一种通常用作杀虫剂的高毒性毒药。
According to Constable Penn, Snowy said he would prefer execution to spending life in prison, but would rather hang himself before the authorities were given the chance to kill him. After the media reported this, Snowy's lawyer denied any suicide attempts had taken place. A few weeks later, the coroner's inquest commenced with the aim of determining for certain whether Louis Caron was deceased, and if so, who or what was the likely cause of his death. Louis's ex-wife, the jeweller who had sold Louis his wedding ring, and Louis's dentist were all flown over from New Zealand to testify, with their expenses covered by the State of Western Australia. Several other witnesses also gave evidence, including Detective Manning, Arthur Upfield, Louis's friend Jack Lemon, Nandi station manager Herman Bogle, and publican Ted Moses. The inquest concluded on February 13, 1932, with Magistrate Edward Butler finding that Louis Caron was indeed dead, and while there was no evidence of the cause of death, Snowy Roles was responsible. Prison officers escorted Snowy to free mental jail to await trial. On March 10, 1932, Snowy's trial commenced before a jury of 12 men, with Justice Percy Draper presiding.
据佩恩警员称，斯诺维表示他宁愿被处决也不愿在监狱里度过余生，但他宁愿在当局有机会杀死他之前自己上吊。媒体报道此事后，斯诺维的律师否认曾发生过任何自杀未遂事件。几周后，验尸官研讯正式开始，旨在确凿判定路易斯·卡隆是否已经死亡，如果属话，谁是或者什么可能是他死亡的可能原因。路易斯的前妻、曾卖给路易斯结婚戒指的珠宝商以及路易斯的牙医都从新西兰飞来作证，他们的费用由西澳大利亚州政府承担。其他几位证人也提供了证据，包括曼宁侦探、亚瑟·厄普菲尔德、路易斯的朋友杰克·莱蒙、南迪站经理赫曼·博格以及酒店老板特德·摩西。研讯于1932年2月13日结束，地方法官爱德华·巴特勒裁定路易斯·卡隆确实已经死亡，虽然没有死因证据，但斯诺维·罗尔斯难辞其咎。监狱看守将斯诺维护送至精神病院等待审判。1932年3月10日，斯诺维的审判在珀西·德雷珀法官的主持下，在由12名男子组成的陪审团面前开始。
At the time, it was the most sensational murder trial in Western Australia's history, and public interest in the case was enormous. Many people were strongly against Snowy, though a majority of Murchison locals who knew him personally wanted to believe that he was innocent. Not only did they find him to be enthusiastic, warm, and hardworking, but they also knew how easily men could disappear in the bush. Sometimes years would pass before a missing person's remains were found, while other times, nothing was recovered at all. Additionally, residents of Murchison were aware that many of the region's transient workers could have various reasons to voluntarily disappear, and believed that the three missing men might have gone off the radar of their own accord. However, the fact that all three had disappeared around the same time, with two of them giving their belongings to Snowy, made it impossible for Murchison locals to disassociate one disappearance from the others. As the trial progressed, Constable Hearn detailed his discovery of the fire pit at the 183-mile gate and the items he found amongst the ashes, while Detective Manning clearly described the course of the investigation. Pathologists testified as to their findings, in particular that the skull fragments and molar tooth were definitely human.
在当时，这是西澳大利亚历史上最轰动的谋杀案审判，公众对该案的关注度极其巨大。许多人强烈反对斯诺维，不过大多数亲自认识他的默奇森当地人更愿意相信他是无辜的。他们不仅发现他热情、温暖且勤劳，而且他们也深知人们在丛林中是多么容易失踪。有时几年过去了，失踪人员的遗骸才被找到，而有时则什么也找不回来。此外，默奇森的居民们意识到，该地区的许多流动工人可能会出于各种原因自愿失踪，并认为这三个失踪人员可能是自愿淡出公众视野的。然而，这三个人都在同一时期失踪，其中两个人还将他们的物品交给了斯诺维，这使得默奇森当地人无法将其中一个失踪案与其它失踪案分离开来。随着审判的推进，赫恩警员详细描述了他发现183英里门火灾坑的经过以及他在灰烬中找到的物品，而曼宁侦探则清晰地描述了调查的过程。病理学家就他们的发现作证，特别是头骨碎片和磨牙绝对是人类的。
The jeweler and dentist who had travelled from New Zealand also provided evidence confirming that the wedding ring, dentures, and molar tooth belonged to Louis Caron. When it was Arthur Upfield's turn to testify, the prosecution alleged that although he was in no way an accessory to the crime, he had inadvertently provided Snowy with a way to destroy the bodies of his victims. Arthur detailed how the fictional disposal method came about for his book, and confirmed that Snowy's roles was fully aware of these details. Crown Prosecutor Clifford Gibson called Snowy's original police statement a tissue of lies. He called witnesses to the stand who were able to rebut Snowy's version of events around the time of Louis Caron's disappearance. Snowy was eventually called to the stand by his defense counsel, Fred Curran. He impressed the court with his unhesitating responses and clear, well-modulated voice, as he essentially repeated the original statement he had provided to Detective Manning. In concluding the defense case, Curran asked Snowy if he knew anything of Louis Caron's present whereabouts, to which Snowy replied, No.
从新西兰赶来的珠宝商和牙医也提供了证据，证实结婚戒指、假牙和磨牙属于路易斯·卡隆。轮到亚瑟·厄普菲尔德出庭作证时，控方指控虽然他绝不是犯罪的从犯，但他无意中为斯诺维提供了一种销毁受害者尸体的方法。亚瑟详细阐述了他的书中的虚构处理方法的由来，并证实斯诺维·罗尔斯对这些细节完全了解。皇家检察官克利福德·吉布森称斯诺维最初的警方供词是一派胡言。他传唤了能够反驳斯诺维在路易斯·卡隆失踪期间的行为说辞的证人出庭。斯诺维最终被他的辩护律师弗雷德·柯伦传唤出庭。他以毫不犹豫的回答和清晰、音调适中的声音给法庭留下了深刻印象，因为他基本上重复了他最初向曼宁侦探提供的供词。在结束辩护陈述时，柯伦问斯诺维是否知道路易斯·卡隆目前的下落，斯诺维回答说：“不知道。”
Curran then asked his client if he had done anything to bring about Louis's death. Again, Snowy said no. Under cross-examination, Prosecutor Gibson asked Snowy why Louis would send him a letter from Geraldton, as Snowy had claimed, yet not make any contact with his close friends Jack Lemon or WA Jackson in New Zealand, whom he wrote to regularly. Snowy responded that he didn't have to account for that. At the conclusion of the trial on March 19, Justice Draper summed up the case for the jury, noting that the discussion between Arthur Upfield and Snowy Rolls about how to destroy a human body without leaving any trace was a curious thing. While he agreed that the evidence indicated the method of disposal had been used in Louis Caron's case, he told the jury, quote, whether Rolls did it is a matter for you to decide. In relation to the wedding ring and artificial teeth found in the fire, Justice Draper observed, quote, It would be a strange coincidence seeing that Caron possessed things identical to all these articles if those found in the fire did not belong to him.
柯伦接着问他的当事人，他是否做了任何导致路易斯死亡的事情。斯诺维再次说没有。在盘问下，检察官吉布森问斯诺维，既然正如斯诺维所声称的那样，路易斯会从杰尔顿给他写信，为什么却不与他在新西兰的挚友杰克·莱蒙或西澳的杰克逊取得任何联系，而他平时经常给他们写信。斯诺维回答说他不需要对此作出解释。在3月19日庭审结束时，德雷珀法官向陪审团总结了此案，指出亚瑟·厄普菲尔德和斯诺维·罗尔斯关于如何完全销毁一具人类尸体而不留任何痕迹的讨论是一件奇怪的事情。虽然他同意证据表明处理方法已被用于路易斯·卡隆的案件中，但他对陪审团说，引述：“罗尔斯是否这样做了，是你们需要决定的事情。”关于火灾中发现的结婚戒指和假牙，德雷珀法官观察道，引述：“考虑到卡隆拥有与所有这些物品完全相同的物品，如果火灾中发现的不属于他，那将是一个奇怪的巧合。”
That afternoon, the jury retired to consider their verdict. Their first task was to decide whether the remains found at the 183-mile camp were in fact those of Louis Caron. According to one juror who spoke to the Daily News after the trial, while the jury was compelled by the presence of the false teeth, shoe eyelets and metal stitches, it was the wedding ring that convinced them that the charge remains belonged to Louis. The evidence given by Jack Lemon that Louis wore the ring on his little finger and had remarked that it was so tight he would have to cut it off, convinced the jury that the ring couldn't possibly have fallen into the fire by accident. They therefore concluded that Louis' finger was either cut off or his whole body was thrown into the flames. The next task for the jury was to decide whether Snowy Rolls was the person responsible. They were unconvinced that Louis had been shot, but were satisfied that the manner in which the bones had been crushed and the ashes were distributed indicated intentional concealment. It was this that they believed was evidence of murder.
那天下午，陪审团退席商议裁决。他们的第一项任务是确定在183英里营地发现的遗骸是否确实是路易斯·卡隆的。根据庭审后对《每日新闻》说话的一名陪审员的说法，虽然陪审团由于假牙、鞋眼和金属线迹的存在而确信无疑，但正是结婚戒指让他们确信受指控的遗骸属于路易斯。杰克·莱蒙提供的证据表明，路易斯将戒指戴在小指上，并曾评论说它太紧了以至于他不得不把它切下来，这让陪审团确信戒指绝对不可能是不小心掉进火里的。因此，他们得出结论，路易斯的要么是手指被切断了，要么是整具尸体被扔进了火焰中。陪审团的下一项任务是决定斯诺维·罗尔斯是否是应该负责的人。他们不相信路易斯是被枪杀的，但他们确信骨头被压碎的方式和灰烬分布的方式表明了蓄意的掩盖。正是这一点，他们认为这是谋杀的证据。
After deliberating for just over two hours, the jury delivered their verdict. Snowy was brought up from the holding cell and stared intently at the jury, shaking his head as though he knew what was coming. The verdict was then read aloud, with the jury finding Snowy Rolls, aka John Thomas Smith, guilty of the murder of Louis Caron. When Justice Draper asked if Snowy had anything to say, he responded, I have been found guilty of a crime that has never been committed. Justice Draper handed down his sentence immediately, declaring, John Thomas Smith, the sentence is that you be returned to your former custody and that at a time and place to be appointed by the governor, you be hanged by the neck until you are dead. May the Lord have mercy on your soul.
经过两个多小时的审议，陪审团给出了裁决。斯诺维被从羁押室带上来，全神贯注地盯着陪审团，摇着头，好像他知道接下来会发生什么。随后，裁决被大声宣读出来，陪审团裁定斯诺维·罗尔斯（又名约翰·托马斯·史密斯）谋杀路易斯·卡隆罪名成立。当德雷珀法官问斯诺维有什么话要说时，他回答道：“我被判犯下了一桩从未发生过的罪行。”德雷珀法官立即下达了判决，宣布：“约翰·托马斯·史密斯，判决是你将被送回你以前的拘留所，并在由总督指定的解时间和地点，将你绞死，直到你死亡。愿上帝怜悯你的灵魂。”
On March 30, Snowy's defense counsel, Fred Caron, lodged an appeal against the conviction. He cited that evidence relating to James Ryan and George Lloyd shouldn't have been admitted, and nor should the evidence provided by Arthur Upfield that Snowy was present during a discussion about the disposal method of a fictional victim. Caron also argued there was no evidence that Louis was dead, and claimed that Justice Draper had misdirected the jury, resulting in a miscarriage of justice. The appeal was heard before the Court of Criminal Appeal on April 15, 1932. Two weeks later, it was unanimously dismissed, with the appellate judges disagreeing with Caron's arguments, and pointing out it was Snowy's own legal counsel who initially raised the association with the James Ryan and George Lloyd during the trial. Snowy's legal team then appealed to the High Court of Australia, but this too was rejected, leaving Snowy with no more formal avenues for appeal. A non-denominational Christian organization known as the Groper Brotherhood protested against Snowy's sentence due to their moral objection to the death penalty.
3月30日，斯诺维的辩护律师弗雷德·卡隆对定罪提起了上诉。他指出，有关詹姆斯·赖安和乔治·劳埃德的证据本不应该被采纳，亚瑟·厄普菲尔德提供的关于斯诺维在场参与讨论虚构受害者处理方法的证据也不应该被采纳。卡隆还辩称，没有证据表明路易斯已经死亡，并声称德雷珀法官对陪审团进行了错误指导，导致了司法不公。上诉于1932年4月15日在刑事上诉法院开庭审理。两周后，上诉被一致驳回，上诉法官不同意卡隆的论点，并指出正是斯诺维自己的法律顾问在审判期间最初挑起了与詹姆斯·赖安和乔治·劳埃德的联系。斯诺维的法律团队随后向澳大利亚高等法院提起上诉，但这也遭到拒绝，这使得斯诺维再也没有更多的正式上诉途径。一个名为“格罗珀兄弟会”的无宗派基督教组织因对死刑的道德反对而抗议斯诺维的判决。
A groper is a slang term for people from Western Australia, taken from the name of an insect native to the state. The Groper Brotherhood made a submission to Western Australia's Executive Council, arguing that the death penalty was designed to be reserved for cases of, quote, repulsive willful murder where there are not mitigating circumstances and where no atonement or reformation can be looked for. As the circumstances of Louis Caron's death had never been established and the evidence used to convict Snowy was mostly circumstantial, the Brotherhood argued it wasn't justified to take Snowy's life. They also claimed that a systematic search hadn't been carried out for James Ryan and George Lloyd and therefore the two men shouldn't have been mentioned at Snowy's trial. According to the Brotherhood, he should be granted mercy pending further police activity on their whereabouts. On June 3, 1932, the Attorney General received the Brotherhood's submission, but declined their request. As explained by Terry Walker in his book Murder on the Rabbit-Proof Fence,
“Groper”是西澳大利亚人的俚语，源自该州本土的一种昆虫。Groper兄弟会向西澳大利亚执行委员会提交了一份意见书，主张死刑应仅保留给那些“令人反感、蓄意谋杀且没有减轻罪责的情节，无法寻求赎罪或改造”的案件。由于路易斯·卡伦（Louis Caron）的死因从未查明，且用于给斯诺伊定罪的证据大多是间接证据，兄弟会认为剥夺斯诺伊的生命是不正当的。他们还声称，当局并未对詹姆斯·赖安（James Ryan）和乔治·洛伊德（George Lloyd）展开系统性搜寻，因此在斯诺伊的审判中不应提及这两人。兄弟会认为，在警方进一步调查他们下落期间，应当对斯诺伊予以宽大处理。1932年6月3日，总检察长收到了兄弟会的意见书，但拒绝了他们的请求。正如特里·沃克（Terry Walker）在他的书《防兔栅栏谋杀案》中所解释的那样，
forbidding the use of circumstantial evidence in murder trials would essentially prevent the prosecution of virtually all murders, other than those committed in front of an impartial and reliable witness. Undeterred, the Brotherhood joined forces with the Housewives Association, who viewed themselves as acting on behalf of Snowy's mother. Together, they amended their objection to the circumstantial evidence. They drew up a formal petition, requesting that Mercy be extended to Snowy so that, quote, He may live to atone in the body for the deeds done in the body, and we, as a Christian society, may discharge our creative and reformative responsibilities to the Father of all. The petition was printed and distributed throughout Perth in the hopes of accumulating signatures. On June 4, 1932, Snowy's lawyer Fred Curran held a press conference in which he announced that Snowy had confessed to what really happened to Louis Curran. Snowy had prepared a statement that read,
在谋杀案审判中禁止使用间接证据，基本上会阻止对几乎所有谋杀案的起诉，除非这些谋杀案是在一个公正可靠的目击者面前发生的。兄弟会并未气馁，他们与家庭主妇协会联合起来，后者认为自己是在代表斯诺伊的母亲行事。他们一起修改了对间接证据的异议。他们起草了一份正式请愿书，请求对斯诺伊宽大处理，以便“他能活着为在肉身中犯下的罪行赎罪，而我们作为一个基督教社会，也能对万物之父履行我们的创造和改造责任。”请愿书被印制并分发到整个珀斯，希望能收集到签名。1932年6月4日，斯诺伊的律师弗雷德·卡兰（Fred Curran）举行了一场新闻发布会，宣布斯诺伊已经承认了对路易斯·卡伦真正发生的事情。斯诺伊准备了一份声明，上面写着：
Curran and I were together. It is true that we camped at the old Windemurrah homestead. The police said we didn't camp there, but we did. We were getting short of stores, and Curran asked me to slip into Painesville and cash his check. He didn't sign it. We hadn't any pens and ink. Curran said to me, You can sign it. And I did. When I got back, I found Curran dead. He had apparently eaten by mistake one of our poisoned butterpats, which we had for poisoning foxes. The body was in terrible condition. The crows had been at it. I was in a rotten position. I had just come back from cashing Curran's check. I had a record and was an escaped prisoner. My first impulse was to go and tell the police, but I knew they would take me and put me in prison. So I decided to do away with the body and say nothing about it. The alleged confession seemed to sway many Perth residents, and the petition against Snowy's execution gained 50,000 signatures. However, it was a different story in the outback, where people became even more convinced of Snowy's guilt.
卡兰和我当时在一起。我们的确在旧温德默拉（Windemurrah）宅基地露营过。警察说我们没有在那里露营，但我们的确去了。我们的物资快用完了，卡兰让我溜进佩恩斯维尔（Painesville）去兑现他的支票。他没有在上面签名。我们没有钢笔和墨水。卡兰对我说，你可以代签。于是我照办了。当我回去时，我发现卡兰已经死了。他显然误食了我们用来毒杀狐狸的有毒黄油块之一。尸体状况非常糟糕。乌鸦已经啄食过它了。我的处境糟透了。我刚从兑现卡兰支票的地方回来。我有犯罪前科，而且是个逃犯。我的第一冲动是去告诉警察，但我知道他们会抓我并把我关进监狱。所以我决定处理掉尸体，并且对此外字不提。所谓的自供似乎左右了许多珀斯的居民，反对处决斯诺伊的请愿书获得了5万个签名。然而，内陆的情况却截然不同，那里的人们更加坚信斯诺伊有罪。
To them, this version of events seemed utterly impossible, especially considering the Windamara homestead where Snowy claimed Louis had died was 80 kilometers from the camp where his remains were then burned. The petition was submitted to the Attorney General on June 7, 1932, with the Executive Council declining to reprieve Snowy, citing that the law must take its course. The following day, a letter from the Groper Brotherhood appeared in the Daily News announcing the organization felt it had discharged its spiritual obligation and was relieved of any further responsibility. Snowy's execution was scheduled for June 13, 1932. Five days prior, his mother and sister visited him at Fremantle Prison, where they described him as being wasted away to a shadow with sunken eyes. Snowy told his mother that he would rather the death sentence over a life in prison. He was also surprised to learn that his confession to his lawyer had been published, as he had only intended for it to be made public after his death. On June 9, the family of George Lloyd sent a telegram from Adelaide, making a final plea for Snowy to tell the truth about what happened to their loved one, but he declined to offer any information. On June 11, Snowy's lawyer Fred Curran published a letter his client had written to him that served as a final public statement. The letter read, There was no receipt. Things are different up in the north to what they are in town. You take a man's word for it.
对他们来说，这种版本的事件经过显得完全不可能，特别是考虑到斯诺伊声称路易斯去世的温达马拉（Windamara）宅基地，距离后来焚烧其遗骸的营地有80公里远。1932年6月7日，请愿书被提交给总检察长，但执行委员会拒绝暂缓执行斯诺伊的死刑，并称法律必须走其正常的程序。第二天，《每日新闻》上刊登了一封来自Groper兄弟会的信，宣布该组织认为自己已经尽到了精神上的义务，并解除了任何进一步的责任。斯诺伊的死刑定于1932年6月13日执行。就在八天前，他的母亲和妹妹在弗里曼特尔监狱探视了他，据她们描述，他当时已经骨瘦如柴，眼窝深陷。斯诺伊告诉母亲，他宁愿被判死刑，也不愿在监狱里度过余生。当他得知自己向律师作出的供词被公开发表时，他也感到很惊讶，因为他原本只打算在自己死后才将其公之于众。6月9日，乔治·洛伊德的家属从阿德莱德发来电报，最后一次恳求斯诺伊说出关于他们亲人遭遇的真相，但他拒绝提供任何信息。6月11日，斯诺伊的律师弗雷德·卡兰发表了他当事人写给他的一封信，作为最后的公开声明。信中写道：根本没有收据。北方的事情和城里不一样。你得信赖一个人说的话。
What I told you the other day was the truth about Louis Curran. I have never taken a man's life. It is not me who has committed murder, but the law. Death can be no worse than what I have gone through for the last few months. I should have told the truth in the first place, but I had to make a fool of myself and I have to pay for it. The law will be satisfied. I can die with a clear mind. At 8am on June 13, Snowy Rolls was hanged at Fremantle Prison. Some news outlets reported that Rolls made no final statement, yet others asserted that his final words were, I did not kill Louis Curran. Snowy's mother inherited her son's small estate, which included the Dodge truck. She attempted to sell it to a motor wrecker, but the police refused to release the vehicle into her possession, arguing that it technically still belonged to the estate of James Ryan. Given that James never married or had children, he had no known heirs, and the Dodge was eventually auctioned off by the government. The proceeds were placed in a trust in case any of James' heirs ever came forward to claim the money, but none ever did. As a result of the case and its links to Arthur Upfield's novel, interest in Arthur's books surged. During Snowy's trial, his first three books were serialised in Western Australian newspapers, further adding to their popularity. Consequently, Arthur moved to Perth's eastern suburbs and started writing full time. In late 1932, he relocated to a small town in Victoria and began writing articles for the Herald newspaper, before once again travelling the countryside.
我前几天对你说的关于路易斯·卡伦的事都是真的。我从来没有剥夺过任何人的生命。犯下谋杀罪的不是我，而是法律。死亡不会比我过去几个月经历的更糟糕。我本该一开始就说实话，但我却把自己弄得像个傻瓜，我必须为此付出代价。法律会得到满足的。我可以带着清醒的头脑死去。6月13日上午8点，斯诺伊·罗尔斯在弗里曼特尔监狱被绞死。一些新闻媒体报道称罗尔斯没有发表最后声明，但另一些媒体则坚称他的遗言是：“我没有杀死路易斯·卡伦。”斯诺伊的母亲继承了她儿子的微小遗产，其中包括那辆道奇卡车。她试图将其卖给汽车拆解商，但警方拒绝将车辆交到她手上，理由是它从技术上讲仍然属于詹姆斯·赖安的遗产。鉴于詹姆斯从未结婚或生育子女，他没有已知的继承人，这辆道奇最终被政府拍卖。所得款项被存入一个信托基金中，以防詹姆士的任何继承人日后现身索取这笔钱，但从来没有人来过。由于该案及其与亚瑟·阿普菲尔德（Arthur Upfield）小说的联系，人们对亚瑟的书籍的兴趣激增。在斯诺伊受审期间，他的前三本书在西澳大利亚的报纸上连载，进一步提高了它们的人气。因此，亚瑟搬到了珀斯的东郊，开始全职写作。1932年末，他搬到了维多利亚州的一个小镇，开始为《先驱报》撰写文章，之后再次开始在乡间游历。
In 1934, Arthur penned his recollection of the Snowy Roll saga for a book titled The Merchants and Murders. Arthur Upfield was essentially Australia's first crime fiction writer. Over the course of his career, he wrote and published 36 novels, the majority of which were part of the Detective Boney series. In 1954, Arthur was the first non-American author to be awarded full membership into the Mystery Writers Guild of America, and in 1957, he was nominated for the Edgar Allan Poe Award for Best Mystery Novel Published in the United States. At the age of 73, Arthur Upfield died of a heart attack in his home in Bowerl, New South Wales. His deep love of the Australian outback lasted throughout his lifetime, with Arthur commenting in his later years, quote, In me was born a passionate love for the Australian bush which will burn until the end, a love stronger than love of family, so strong that even now it threatens to claim me. Capital punishment was abolished in Western Australia in 1984, with Snowy Rolls being the sixth last person ever executed in the state. Although James Ryan and George Lloyd were eventually declared legally dead, no one was ever charged for their murders, and none of their remains were ever formally identified.
1934年，亚瑟在一本名为《商人与谋杀案》的书里记述了他对斯诺伊·罗尔斯传奇的回忆。亚瑟·阿普菲尔德基本上是澳大利亚的第一位犯罪小说作家。在他的职业生涯中，他创作并出版了36部小说，其中大部分是“邦尼侦探”（Detective Boney）系列的一部分。1954年，亚瑟成为第一位获得美国推理作家协会全权会员资格的非美国作家；1957年，他被提名竞选爱伦·坡奖的最佳美国出版悬疑小说奖。享年73岁时，亚瑟·阿普菲尔德在新南威尔士州鲍勒尔的家中因心脏病发作去世。他对澳大利亚内陆的深厚热爱贯穿了他的一生，亚瑟在晚年时曾评论道：“在我体内诞生了一种对澳大利亚灌木林的热情，这种爱将燃烧到尽头，比对家庭的爱更强烈，甚至在现在，它也威胁着要将我夺走。”西澳大利亚州于1984年废除了死刑，斯诺伊·罗尔斯是该州倒数第六名被执行死刑的人。尽管詹姆斯·赖安和乔治·洛伊德最终被宣方法定死亡，但从未有人因谋杀他们而被起诉，他们的遗骸也从未被正式鉴定身份。
However, many were convinced that they both suffered the same fate as Louis Caron. Detective Manning stated, As a result of my inquiries, I don't think there is any doubt that both Ryan and Lloyd were murdered at Charlie Bore, and then their bodies cut up and burned on the different fires. Over the years, the rabbit-proof fence proved ineffective, with rabbits and other animals managing to make their way through gaps or via open gates, which travelers often failed to close. By the late 1940s, the grand ideal of one great vermin-thwarting coast-to-coast fence had started to fade. This feeling of defeat, coupled with the fact that many Aussie men were called away from the upback to go to war, meant it became difficult to keep the fence in good repair. As the century progressed, the Western Australian government abandoned stretches of the number one rabbit-proof fence, from Gum Creek Junction to the North Coast, and from the South Coast to the 76-mile post north of Barakopin. The remaining portion became important for repelling wild dogs and emus, and therefore continues to be maintained.
然而，许多人确信他们两人的遭遇与路易斯·卡伦相同。曼宁侦探表示：“根据我的调查，我认为毫无疑问，赖安和洛伊德都在查理波尔（Charlie Bore）被谋杀，然后尸体被肢解并在不同的火堆中焚烧。”多年来，事实证明防兔栅栏并没有起到什么效果，兔子和其他动物设法穿过了豁口，或者通过了旅客经常忘记关上的敞开的大门。到了20世纪40年代末，那道横跨海岸、旨在阻挡害兽的宏大防线的美好理想开始破灭。这种受挫感，再加上许多澳大利亚男子被从内陆召集去参战，意味着很难将栅栏维持在良好的维修状态。随着世纪的推移，西澳大利亚州政府放弃了从吉姆克雷克交汇处（Gum Creek Junction）到北海岸，以及从南海岸到巴拉科平（Barakopin）以北76英里处的一段段一号防兔栅栏。其余部分对于驱赶野狗和鸸鹋变得很重要，因此得以继续维护。
In 1989, author Terry Walker visited the untended 183-mile camp north of Camel Station, where the remains of Louis Caron were found. In his book about the case titled, Murder on the Rabbit-Proof Fence, Terry wrote, Much has changed at the haunted camp. New fences passed through the area, although the 183-mile gate still swings, rather reluctantly, on its rusty hinges. There is nothing there to suggest that it was the scene of a murder. Despite its dilapidated state, Camel Station was added to the Western Australia Heritage Register in March 2018, for its association with the killings. In an article for the West Australian newspaper, Heritage Minister David Templeman said the heritage listing, Incapsulates the fascinating story of the mergers and murders, and the hard and isolated life of boundary riders, on the rabbit-proof fence. Copyright© OSHO International Foundation There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
1989年，作家特里·沃克（Terry Walker）参观了位于骆驼站（Camel Station）以北无人看管的183英里营地，路易斯·卡伦的遗骸就是在那里被发现的。在他关于这起案件的书《防兔栅栏谋杀案》中，特里写道：“闹鬼的营地发生了很大变化。新的栅栏穿过了该地区，尽管183英里的门仍然在其生锈的铰链上有些不情愿地摇晃着。那里没有任何迹象表明这里曾是谋杀现场。”尽管处于失修状态，骆驼站还是因其与这些谋杀案的联系，于2018年3月被列入西澳大利亚州遗产名录。遗产部长大卫·坦普尔曼（David Templeman）在为《西澳大利亚人报》撰写的一篇文章中表示，被列入遗产名录“概括了合并案与谋杀案的迷人故事，以及防兔栅栏上巡线员艰苦而孤立的生活。”版权所有 © OSHO国际基金会 本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。